Also ich, ich hab drei Jungs da draußen.
Die sind drauf und dran, dich alle zu machen.
Ist das nicht eine Punkband?
Ich werd mit den Knaben schon fertig.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 57. Eigentlich muss ich sogar sagen 57a, denn jetzt haben wir es auch geschafft, alle Mikrofone einzuschalten, dass die Sendung auch aufgenommen wird. Also wir starten hier gerade nochmal ins neue, nicht ins neue Jahr, aber ins neue Thema. Und wir schreiben den 29. November 2007.
Immer noch.
Und ich bin hier versammelt mit einer Punk-Band und ihr hört es auch schon im Hintergrund. Sie sind vorlaut, sie sind wild, sie sind Rebellen, sie sind Revolutionäre. Die Allstars, genau. Die BitTorrent-Allstars. Von links nach rechts Erdgeist.
Hallo!
Der Cryx.
Und Denis. Moin moin. So, unser Thema soll sein BitTorrent. Und vielleicht die Leute, die in den letzten zwei Jahren keine Nachrichten verfolgt haben, wissen noch nicht, dass BitTorrent heutzutage das populärste Protokoll ist auf dem Internet. Die Statistik stimmt, ja.
TCP kommt noch davor, aber...
60... Ah super, wir machen jetzt alle Witze nochmal. Das ist gut, ne? Gut, dass wir noch nicht so viele gemacht haben. Aber wie ist denn das eigentlich? Wo kommt denn diese Statistik eigentlich her? Wie viel Traffic im Internet durch welche Protokolle belegt wird? Wer gibt das raus?
Also da gibt es so verschiedene Firmen, die da Statistiken machen. Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel eine Statistik, die sagt, was von zwischen 49 bis 83 Prozent allen Internet-Traffics wäre Peer-to-Peer und halt auch zum Großteil BitTorrent.
83 Prozent? Also alle Daten, die überhaupt durch irgendwelche Internetroutern durchgeschaufelt werden, sind?
95 Prozent während der Nacht.
Wie, was 95 Prozent?
95 Prozent ist während der Nacht.
Welchen Nacht? Also Nacht ist immer.
Das ist sogar eine deutsche Firma, das kann ja nur Qualität.
Aber aus Deutschland kommen auch die Seiten, die um 18 Uhr zumachen.
Okay, ich glaube, keiner Statistik, die du nicht selbst gefälscht hast. Letztlich ist vollkommen klar, BitTorrent ist extrem populär. 2001 oder 2002 hat das irgendwann angefangen und ein Mensch namens Bram Cohen hat ein neues Programm vorgestellt namens BitTorrent, was halt auch ein neues Protokoll implementiert hat namens BitTorrent. Und ja, dann war auf einmal irgendwie alles anders. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, damals so…
Ich habe einen Slashdot-Artikel darüber, dass man jetzt einen neuen Weg, um schnell Files runterladen zu können. Ich habe das irgendwie ausgebildet. Bei Mac haben wir irgendwie so einen Python-geschriebenen Client und Version 2.7 oder so was. Da habe ich so einen 100 MB-File runtergeladen und dann war es da und dann dachte ich, ja, habe ich jetzt einen File runterladen und habe nicht so verstanden, warum das jetzt irgendwie toller sein würde. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob damals dieses Tool auch schon von anderen Clients aus runtergeladen war, weil das konnte man alles gar nicht sehen und deswegen fand ich es erst mal noch nicht so special, aber dann so ein paar Monate später kam es.
Hat es klick gemacht? Und was hast du da begriffen? Und warum?
Weil es mit anderen noch eine Connection gibt, die das Gleiche runterladen und dann tauschen sie aufeinander aus und zwar in random order.
Zauberwort Peer-to-Peer, richtig? Das heißt, anders als man das so normalerweise im Downloadsystem hat, mit ich klicke auf Server-Datei an und dann wird die zu mir rübergeschickt, so. Geht es halt anders. Aber Peer-to-Peer-Protokolle gab es ja auch schon vorher.
Aber die hatten ja alle ihren Fokus darauf gelegt, dass man ein großes Verzeichnisbund um seine ganze Vers reingelegt hat, allen zur Verfügung stellt und da hat dann allein schon der Overhead des Announcens, was man da in darum liegen hat und das Finden der Dateien einen Großteil des Traffics ausgemacht.
Und das ist halt nie besonders...
Ja genau, die anderen sind sozusagen ein Full Service gewesen und waren aber dadurch auch leichter tot zu schlagen. Weil man... Sind eigentlich alle tot. Ja, BitTorrent hat komplett übernommen, hat man so den Eindruck. Ist so, ne? Und ja, vielleicht sollte man jetzt mal ein bisschen aufschüsseln, was eigentlich, ja, was macht jetzt eigentlich BitTorrent aus und wo ist so der entscheidende Unterschied zu diesen anderen Sachen. Also wir haben schon gesagt, die Distribution der Information, was man da so finden kann. Also es geht nicht darum, ein Netz zu bieten, in dem man suchen kann. Das ist so ein bisschen auch so die Einsicht, man hat ja eh schon Suchmaschinen, da kann man irgendwie eh besser suchen. Da muss man jetzt das Rad nicht nochmal neu erfinden. Genau, also konzentriert man sich einfach auf das Wesentliche und das Wesentliche ist, die Dateien möglichst effizient zu verteilen. Ziel ist ja, dass man irgendwas schnell bekommt. Und das Problem ist, wenn irgendeine Datei extrem populär ist und ein Server bietet die an, es wollen nur eine Million Leute das irgendwie runterladen, dann kriegt irgendwie jeder einen Byte pro Sekunde und alle warten bis...
Ganz schlicht, man hat den millionenfachen Traffic, wenn Millionen Clients den haben wollen.
Bei FDP wäre das so zum Beispiel. Deswegen skaliert FDP nicht, deswegen haben die sich was anderes einfallen. Und Brian Conner glaube ich ziemlich lange, da wir sessen, ist er auch so ein richtiger WC-Nörd, er war wohl WC-Fan.
Ach echt? Hat er so Doku gespielt oder was?
Jedenfalls hat er sich hingesetzt und hat sich mal überlegt, wie man es machen müsste, wahrscheinlich wir uns das alles schon überlegt haben, weil es ist eigentlich noch nicht so schwer, dass man sich denkt, die Leute, die es runterladen, haben ja schon ein bisschen der Information, während sie runterladen und könnten die gleichzeitig auch wieder rausschieben. Also dass man deren Bandbreite auch mitnutzt. Er hat nicht nur darüber nachgedacht, sondern hat sich auch hingesetzt und das mal implementiert. Und ziemlich gut, wie man sieht.
Sonst würde das Protokoll heute nicht mehr geben, weil so lange auszahlen ist schon nicht so schlecht. Was macht ein BitTorrent-System aus? Welche Komponenten gibt es? Also man hat irgendwie so ein Klein, man lässt sich eine Software runterladen.
Einfach mal anfangen, du möchtest eine Datei, die bei dir auf deiner Festplatte rumliegt, möchtest du mal über BitTorrent an viele Leute verteilen. Du weißt ganz genau, das ist ja so...
Okay, also ich hab hier so mein Heim-Porno, DVD.
Genau, und du weißt ganz genau, das ist so spezieller Porn, den wollen jetzt alle haben.
So ein Nerdcore.
Genau, und du weißt, wenn du das auf deinem FDP-Server hinlegen würdest, dann wär's der Pleite, weil dein ISP dich...
Live-Video-Mitschnitte von Chaosradio Express-Aufzeichnung.
Ja, also gehst du jetzt da her. Und was die sich da in BitTorrent gedacht haben, ist, zerstückelen wir mal diese Datei in so möglichst gleich große Teile, die noch überschaubar sind.
Das sind die sogenannten... Genau.
Und jetzt wollen wir ganz sicher sein, dass alle Leute, die sich Pieces von irgendjemanden runtergeladen haben, auch wirklich diese Pieces bekommen. Also hat sich der Protokoll-Designer gedacht, wir machen da mal eine Check-Summe drüber. So Check-Summen sind so Fingerabdrücke, die aus einer großen Menge von Daten...
Warte mal langsam. Also ich meine... Was mache ich denn als erstes? Ich habe die Datei, und die soll jetzt irgendwie verteilt werden. Was ist der allererste Schritt, den ich jetzt machen muss?
Du musst erst mal die sogenannte Torrent-Datei erstellen, die immer mit Punkt Torrent irgendwie ändert. Zum Beispiel, mein-pauno.torrent, und das macht deinen BitTorrent klein. Meistens für dich, wenn nicht, gibt es ein Extra-Tool. Damals war es ein Python-Sauce, da gab es halt ein... maketorrent.com Und das geht über deine 700 Megabyte-Datei rüber, zerstüppelt die bei 700 MB wahrscheinlich in 1 MB Stücke.
Man geht in seinen Kleinen und sagt, macht Torrent von der Datei tralala.
Er stellt also 700 Hashes davon.
Das heißt, der teilt das in diese Pieces auf. Und für jedes Piece berechnet er eine Checksumme und sagt, mit dieser Checksumme kann man jetzt die Integrität dieses Teils überprüfen. Und wie groß ist so ein Piece?
Das kommt ganz darauf an, wie groß das Pfeil am Ende ist. Weil du möchtest ja auch, dass, wenn du ziemlich viele kleine Pieces hast, dann würde der Torrent-Pfeil selber ziemlich groß und keiner will das runterladen. Also musst du so eine Balance finden. Und üblicherweise wird es so gewählt, dass das Torrent-Pfeil zwischen 70 und 100 Kilobyte groß ist.
Das heißt, das macht der Klein für mich automatisch?
Das berechnet der Klein schon für dich.
Das große Datei heißt größere Pieces? Das kann man auch nicht so groß haben, weil da kommen wir später noch zu. So, das heißt, jetzt habe ich diese Punkt-Torrent-Datei, irgendwie mein Home-Porn Punkt-Torrent, und wir haben jetzt N Pieces in dieser Datei, und das steht hier drin. Da steht aber noch ein ganz wichtiger Spektrum.
Und zwar trägst du noch einen, der dann verantwortlich ist für die ganze Verteilung, nämlich den Trecker.
Okay, das heißt, neben dem Klein, den ich jetzt schon benutze, gibt es auch noch einen Trecker.
Genau, die sogenannte Mitfahrzentrale.
Der alles managt.
Zu diesem Trecker-Protokoll kommen wir nachher noch.
Der managt, dass die Kleins sich finden.
Das ist wirklich wie eine Mitfahrzentrale. Du gehst dahin und sagst, ich habe einen Torrent, der sieht so und so aus. Jetzt wird dieses Torrent-Fall wieder genommen, wird genauso eine Checksumme drüber berechnet wie über die einzelnen Pieces. Und diese Checksumme identifiziert so einen Torrent dann eindeutig. Das ist schon ziemlich unwahrscheinlich.
Aber woher weiß ich denn überhaupt, wo dieser Torrent ist?
Wo der Torrent ist?
Ja, der Trecker ist ja... Muss ich kennen. Und woher kenne ich den?
Gibt es im Internet.
Meistens tragen die schon welche ein. Bieten ja schon welche in einer Liste an.
Ja, er hat sich rumgesprochen. Okay, das heißt, es gibt Trecker, die laufen im Internet. Und die darf ich dann alle benutzen.
Früher war das noch ziemlich exklusiv.
Das heißt, ich suche mir einfach einen aus, und den suche ich mir danach aus, ob der mir sympathisch ist. Ob der einen coolen Namen hat. Die machen eigentlich alle dasselbe. Es gibt jetzt keinen Trecker, der irgendwie was ganz anderes tut.
Und dann zudem trägt man auch einfach eine ganze komplette Liste rein. Also nicht nur einen, sondern halt...
Das heißt, in dieser Torrent-Datei sind die Pieces für jedes Piece. Genau, also diese Checksummen sozusagen. Und eine Information, welcher Trecker diese Datei verteilen soll. Sie ist also fest hard codiert in der Datei drin.
Und dann noch ein bisschen Meternfotos, Informationen, welcher Klein das Torrent vererstellt hat, zu welchem Datum das gewesen ist. Und dann kannst du noch einen Kommentar reinmachen und so. Und die Feilnamen der einzelnen Feils.
Okay, aber wenn man so eine DVD hat, mit Video, TS-Ordner und so weiter, dass jede einzelne Datei ist dort auch noch erwähnt. Das heißt, wenn man einen Torrent-Fall hat, dann weiß man ganz genau, wie soll das irgendwie heißen, wie heißt jede einzelne Datei, also die komplette Hierarchie aller Feils, die da drin sind. Das heißt, man muss das auch nicht zippen. Aber häufig verwenden die Leute ja trotzdem noch mal so ein Radhuls, was ja eigentlich totaler Quatsch ist. Es ist eigentlich Blödsinn. Also man kann komplette Feilsystem-Hierarchien und nicht nur einzelne Dateien in einen Torrent-Fall verewigen.
Ja, das kommt daher, dass es früher einfach noch nicht möglich war, mehrere Feils reinzutun. Da konnte man nur einen Fall scheren, und dann haben die Kleinstestungen von allen gekonnt, und die Leute haben noch die alten Kleinstestungen, und machen dann vorher noch einen SIP draus oder einen RAV.
Diese RAV-Geschichte kommt eigentlich, also wenn sozusagen in diesem Fall, was man schert, mehrere RAV-Heils drinnen sind, wenn jetzt irgendwo ein Video runterlädt oder so, das kommt eigentlich aus dem Newsnet da, wo die DVD-Rips halt herkommen, weil im Newsnet wird pro Post ein RAV-Feil gepostet. Und da kommt halt diese Aufteilung her. Und das gibt es halt bei BitTorrent dann nicht mehr, und die Leute sind dann zu faul, dieses RA zu entpacken.
Wo kommt eigentlich dieses RA her? Das ist doch echt eine Seuche, oder?
Andere Baustelle, anderes Thema.
Gut, also jetzt habe ich irgendwie meine Torrent-Datei. Und ich habe mir jetzt irgendeinen Trecker geklickt, so in dem Moment, wo ich das erstellt habe. Das heißt, da steht jetzt alles in dieser Datei drin. So, und jetzt möchte ich gerne meinen Home-Porno irgendwie an Omi und Opi schicken.
Dann schickst du eine E-Mail an Omi und Opi, oder du lädst das Torrent-File auf deinen Web-Server hoch, oder du suchst dir einen der größeren Indexer und lädst deine Torrent-Datei da hoch.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Torrent-Datei enthält alles, was man braucht, um die Datei zu laden. Und ich muss eigentlich nur dafür sorgen, dass die ihren Weg irgendwo hin findet.
Ja, dazu hilft es, die ordentlich zu benennen. Man kann es natürlich kryptisch benennen und nur seinen Freunden geben, dann findet es keiner so schnell. Du kannst aber auch, wenn du möchtest, viele Leute sehen, wie du zu Hause deine...
Ja, ich meine, wenn ich das auf meine Homepage packe und sage, hier, irgendwie geiler Heim-Porno, dann ist das ja egal, ob die Datei XYZ.torrent heißt oder... Genau, weil es steht ja alles in der Torrent-Datei drin. Ich glaube, das ist eine relativ wichtige Sache, dass einfach diese eine Torrent-Datei eigentlich alles enthält mit Metadaten und Filenames und so weiter.
Ja, ich würde noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass die Checksum und Hash irgendwie ein und dasselbe sind, über denen dieses Torrent identifiziert wird.
Was ist denn das für ein Algorithmus, der da benutzt wird?
Das ist SHA1. Ja, da kommen 160 Bit raus. Das sind so 20 Byte an Daten, die eindeutig so einen Torrent identifizieren. Und üblicherweise ist es ziemlich...
Wie sicher sind denn eigentlich diese Checksum-Algorithmen?
Was meinst du mit sicher?
Na ja, also ich meine...
Gegen was?
Na wenn jetzt so ein Piece irgendwie falsch übertragen wird und so eine Checksum wird verglichen...
Also wenn es nur wirklich fehlerhaft ist wegen des Internets, wegen der Route, dann ist es schon eigentlich so unsicher, dass du es einfach in deinem Leben nicht erleben wirst, dass halt durch Zufall zwei Pieces denselben Hashtar, die über dir ankommen.
Gut, das heißt, diese Checksum stellt halt sicher, dass wenn ich irgendein Piece von irgendjemand bekomme, und das ist ja jetzt die Idee bei BitTorrent, ich bekomme meine Datei nicht als Ganzes, sondern eben in Pieces. Und die Pieces können halt von irgendjemand kommen. Und zwar von anderen Leuten, die die ganze Datei... Jetzt haben wir mal ein bisschen gesprochen.
Erstmal dein Opie, der jetzt seine Tochen-Datei bekommen hat, starten hier ein BitTorrent-Client, der geht da rein, holt sich die ganzen Hashes daraus und aber auch die Tracker-Adresse, connectet zu dem Tracker und fragt, wer hat dann noch dieses Pfeil angeboten?
Nein, der wichtige Punkt ist nicht, nein, ich möchte dieses Pfeil und wer hat es noch? Das ist der wichtige Teil, dass du halt sagst, ich möchte dahin fahren, mit Fahrzentrale, das Bild wieder, ich möchte von Berlin nach Dresden fahren, das ist so, fährt euch zufäll auch noch irgendjemand und wenn noch niemand fährt, dann sagt mal später, wenn jemand fragt auch noch Bescheid. Das ist so die Idee vom Tracker.
Deiner muss jetzt auch noch laufen, sonst legst du ja nicht hoch, du musst deinen BitTorrent-Leit natürlich auch starten. Dann sind es jetzt schon zwei, und zwar du hast alles, dein Omi und dein Upi noch nicht, also werden die von dir in zufälliger Reihenfolge diese Pieces anfordern. Dann schickst du denen eins rüber und dann haben sie eins und können sogar prüfen, dass es das Richtige ist, anhand von der Schicksung.
Also, um es nochmal ganz einfach aufzuteilen, ich muss jetzt überhaupt erstmal die Datei ja auch anbieten. Weil zunächst einmal liegt sie ja auf meinem Rechner. Das heißt, ich starte mal einen kleinen und sage, hier ist jetzt die Torrent-Datei, friss und biete an. Und dann verbindet sich mein Client an den Trecker, der in dieser Torrent-Datei drin steht und sagt, Hallo, ich bin's, ich habe diese Datei. Oder was sagt der dem Trecker?
Der sagt, ich habe diesen Hasch. Das funktioniert nämlich genauso wie über die einzelnen Pieces. Das heißt, über die gesamten Torrenten wird nochmal wieder ein Hasch berechnet. Und dieser Hasch schickst du einfach dem Trecker.
Also eine ID, die dabei rauskommt.
Wieder ein Fingerabdruck, wieder eine Checksumme, genau wie die Pieces auch. Auch wieder SHA1, genau dasselbe.
Sodass der Trecker die ganzen Torrent-Dateien relativ einfach an einer einzigen Zahl auseinanderhalten kann.
Ja, das gefällt mir als Programmierer auch ganz gut, weil das ist ein Hasch, man kann halt dafür sorgen, dass sich das irgendwie schön verteilt in den einzelnen Pools, die man selber vorhalten muss. Da wollten wir erst nachher zu kommen.
Sprich deine Dreckige Programmierersprache. Da will keiner mehr was verstehen.
Nehmen wir Ihren Hasch wieder, also Ihre Torrent-ID, connect zu dem Trecker. Dann sagt der Trecker auch, interessant, da ist schon anderer da. Der sagt sogar, er ist Cedar, da kommen wir auch gleich noch zu. Und dann verbindet sich dein Klein direkt mit der Adresse von Umi und Opi. Wer zu wem connectet, das ist noch ein bisschen unklar, weil da kommt ja noch ein Nackenspül, da können wir auch gleich noch auseinanderdrehen. Aber ihr habt erst mal eine Verbindung. Und dann können die Kleines untereinander managen, welche Blöcke fehlen, welche sie haben wollen.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich der Erste bin, der mit dieser ID ankommt, merkt sich der Trecker, alles klar, eine weitere Datei soll dem Internet zugänglich gemacht werden, speichert das irgendwo ab in seinem Speicher. Und in dem Moment, wo der Zweite kommt und fragt, kennst du jemanden, der das hat, schaut er nach, mal kieken irgendwie, die ID hab ich doch schon mal gesehen, ah ja, da gibt's sowieso. Das heißt, er reicht nun die Information, dass ich das habe, an den ersten, der das haben möchte, weiter in Form einer IP-Adresse und eines Ports. Das heißt, er leitet die Connection-Informationen weiter. Und sonst macht er nichts?
Nichts. In Wirklichkeit werden ihm noch ein paar Informationen übertragen, die aber beliebig gefälscht werden können. Wo er sagen kann, wie viele Teile er schon runtergeladen hat. Oder wo er sagen kann, dass er in einer anderen IP zu erreichen ist. Aber in Wirklichkeit ist es immer nur spannend, wo er wirklich...
Im groben und ganzen weiß er nur einen Hasch und dazu eine Liste von IP-Adressen plus Ports. Das ist das, was der Trecker weiß und mehr weiß er nicht.
Das ist ja eigentlich erstmal ganz schön wenig, aber es ist auch eine ganz interessante Information. Weil in dem Moment, wo man, sagen wir mal so, partiell legale Inhalte über das Internet verteilt, sollte man sich schon klar machen, dass ja eigentlich von jedem, der anbietet und also jedem, der runterlädt und jeder, der natürlich auch damit automatisch Sachen anbietet, teile anbietet dieser Datei oder auch eben das Ganze, der macht seine Verbindungsinformation, seine IP-Adresse und damit ja potentiell auch sich selbst. Das wissen wir ja alle, wenn die legale Exekutive kommt und sagt, jetzt müssen wir mal genau wissen, wer zu diesem Zeitpunkt in dieser IP-Adresse sozusagen seinen Computer eingeschaltet hat, dann kriegt man das schon raus. Also man ist nicht anonym bei BVB.
Das ist wie eine öffentliche Webseite für eine Mitfahrzentrale, auf der steht, wer alles von Berlin nach Hamburg fährt und zwar jetzt.
Und das heißt auch, wenn so ein Torrent-File öffentlich verfügbar ist, wie das ja heute eigentlich gang und gäbe ist, dann geht da irgendwie auf Pirate Bay, tralala, hier neue Version Mac OS 10, ZIN 5 oder hier neuer RIP The Simpsons, dann kann sich ja eigentlich jeder beliebige Verfolger, in Einführungsstrichen, eigentlich dieses Torrent-File ziehen, ein Programm starten und kriegt dann schön die IP-Adressen von allen Leuten, die sich das gerade runterladen wollen.
Nein, das geht natürlich, wenn er das will. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich für die Leute, die Trecker betreiben, auch die Möglichkeit, dort beliebige Informationen in die Antwort hinein zu tun. Weil es wird ja erst spannend, wenn es viele Clients gibt, also viele Peers gibt, viele Leute, die mit einem die Datei teilen wollen. Und es reicht ja für den, der es wirklich legitim machen möchte, schon aus, wenn da irgendwie ein oder zwei von denen wirklich legitim sind, wenn man halt wie noch ganz viele andere zufällige Daten da rein tut.
Meinst du, dass der Trecker das bewusst vergiftet?
Der Trecker kann ganz bewusst dafür sorgen, dass, nur nicht vergiften.
Dass er falsche Informationen liefert, oder was?
Verwässern, ja. Also er könnte jetzt, er könnte zu dem, er könnte falsche IP-Adressen liefern.
Genau.
Bezüglich randomisiert.
Tun sie das auch?
Es gibt so ein Vertitutes.
Das ist ja interessant. Und das heißt, dass die ein echtes Problem haben, wirklich zu beweisen, dass hinter dieser IP-Adresse tatsächlich was, ein echter Datenzieher und Anbieter steckt, weil es könnte sich auch eine komplett falsche Information haben.
Das Ding bei der Sache ist, es gab halt den Fall, dass Firmen, die sozusagen Copyright Violations oder sowas verfolgt haben, die haben halt angefangen, die Trecker zu befragen, wer shared dann jetzt gerade dieses File? Und haben sich dann die IP-Adressen genommen und haben halt angefangen, sofort Klagebriefe herauszuschicken. Aber in so einem Trecker drin zu stehen, in so einer Liste, ist ja noch lange kein Beweis dafür, dass du irgendwelche Daten verteilst, die urheberrechtlich geschützt sind. Und sie müssten eigentlich erst anfangen, diesen Download zu starten und sozusagen von dir erst etwas zu bekommen. Und zwar das Vollständige eigentlich, wobei es da auch noch geteilte Auffassungen gibt, bevor sie dir sozusagen beweisen können, dass du wirklich daran beteiligt bist, diese...
Ein Piece würde da eigentlich reichen, oder?
Nein, ein Piece reicht eben nicht. Ein Piece könnte eventuell reichen, ja, aber...
Ich meine, die Wahrscheinlichkeit...
Der Aufwand ist deutlich höher, sich ein ganzes Piece von einem einzigen Kleinen zusammenzuholen, passiert nicht, weil in Wirklichkeit innerhalb des P2P-Protokolls werden diese Pieces auch wieder in Blöcke unterteilt, die dann halt in viel kleineren Einheiten von auch wieder allen möglichen anderen zusammen betragen werden. Dann wird es nämlich echt haarig. Aber dann lassen wir es später.
Da können wir ja ruhig mal wieder einscheren. Oder hast du da jetzt noch einen wichtigen Aspekt?
Ja, der wichtige Aspekt, wenn man in der Treckerliste drin steht, ist nämlich, dass das Protokoll, was sie sprechen, um sich beim Trecker anzumelden, ist HTTP. Und damit reicht es schon, wenn du irgendeinen Pixel-Bug oder irgendeinen beliebten Link nimmst, die Browser, den du auf der Seite packst und wie man surft auf deiner Seite und legt natürlich automatisch den Source runter.
Was? Moment, das habe ich nicht verstanden. Wer verbindet sich mit wem mit HTTP?
Wenn Oma und Opa dem Trecker Bescheid sagen, dass sie dieses File runterladen möchten, benutzen sie dazu das Protokoll HTTP. Was ich für eine ziemlich blöde Idee halte, aber da kommen wir später dazu.
Also der Kleine verbindet sich mit dem Trecker, in dem er HTTP benutzt.
So einen Link könnte man auf einer Webseite packen. Den könnte ich dir hier hochmarkieren, diese Seite, und dann kannst du ihn an und in die Möglichkeit einlegen, davon geht es in den Trecker.
Na gut, aber dadurch wird er dich automatisch...
Damit bist du dann in der Treckerliste.
Der Trecker trägt mich sofort ein.
Weil da ist nichts mehr dabei als Oma und Opa.
Aber dann muss er auch noch irgendwie die Hash-ID und so weiter...
Die kannst du ja mit dem URL tun.
Ach so, ich kann einen Link auf einer Webseite so machen, dass, wenn er angeklickt wird, das für den Trecker, der dahinter steht, so aussieht, als ob da ein legaler Request nach einer Datei ist. Wie sieht so ein Link denn aus?
Das ist üblicherweise, ja, meistens sogar Port 80.
Ja, Fragezeichen, Info-Hash-Gleich.
Das heißt, die vollständige Information steht in einer URL. Okay, und ist das jetzt eine kluge Idee?
Da kommt drauf an, also es führt dazu, dass du aus allen möglichen Netzwerken, die wirklich nichts weiter als HTTP erlauben, deinen BitTorrent annuncen kannst. Das führt aber auch wieder dazu, dass du, wenn du eh nichts weiter als HTTP machen kannst, da auch nicht aus diesem Netz raus kannst, was dann schon wieder...
Okay, aber es bietet dann auch gleich wieder diese Hintertür, wie wir das jetzt gerade besprochen haben. Wenn ich irgendwo diesen Link einfach mal so reinpfeffer, dann generiere ich eine Menge Leute, die das anbieten. Na gut, aber dann läuft natürlich immer noch kein BitTorrent dahinter. Das heißt, in dem Fall, wo jetzt wirklich auch jemand über BitTorrent etwas anbietet, also auch tatsächlich am Vertrieb dieser Datei teilnimmt, und eher Daten liefert, dann sieht es schon mal anders aus.
Na wir lassen uns doch mal die Aspekte dann, wenn wir das Protokoll peer-to-peer zu Ende erklärt haben, dann wird es schon viel klarer, was genau passiert und was dann möglich ist. Weil halt, wenn Omi und Opi nämlich jetzt angefangen haben, sich beim Tracker anzumelden und die Adresse von dir bekommen haben, und man wegen Onkel und Tante das jetzt auch noch machen, dann hat jeder drei Adressen, also seine eigene, und die von Omi und Opi und die von Onkel und Tante.
Okay, das heißt, wir sprechen mal einfacher. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie A, B und C. A hat alles und B und C haben nix.
Das juckt dann in dem Moment gar nichts mehr. Die sind alle gleichberechtigt. Eine hat durch Zufall alle Blöcke. Die anderen haben gerade noch keine Blöcke, aber die sprechen miteinander als gleichberechtigte Partner. Pieces, verzeih. Eine hat alle Pieces, die anderen haben noch keine. Aber ansonsten sind sie gleichberechtigte Partner, die jetzt anfangen, sich Nachrichten hin und her zu schicken, indem sie erzählen, welche Pieces sie von Anfang an hatten, indem sie erzählen, welche Pieces sie gerade dazu bekommen haben und auch überprüft haben und welche Pieces sie gerne von ihren anderen Piers haben wollen.
Das heißt, es wird immer eine Liste von allen Pieces aufrechterhalten für jede herunterzuladende Datei.
Genau. Am Anfang bekommt man einmal ein Bitfeld, in dem einfach eine 1 ist für, ich habe dieses Piece, eine 0 ist, ich habe dieses Piece nicht. Und damit kann man schon mal initialisieren, was man über den anderen Pier weiß. Und danach, guckt man danach, wo eine 1 stehen hat, da kann ich ja mal nachfragen, wenn ich da eine 0 stehen habe, in der Liste für meine eigene Pier ist. Also ich komme wie auch so in ein Bitfeld für meine eigenen Pieces und würde dann halt da, wo sie mir noch fehlen, einfach genau diese Pieces nachfragen.
Bei Bitfeldern. Okay, also im Prinzip, alle Clients blicken auf diese Datei aufgeteilt in Pieces. Und jedes Pieces ist dann aber auch nochmal aufgeteilt in Blöcke.
Das ist...
Oder ist das jetzt dasselbe?
Nee, ein Block ist einfach innerhalb eines Pieces ein Stück ab irgendeiner bestimmten Adresse mit einer bestimmten Länge. Weil halt üblicherweise möchtest du nicht einen Megabyte am Stück von jemanden herunterladen, sondern sagst, ich hätte jetzt gerne aus diesem Piece von Stelle 5000 bis 10.000 mal den Block.
Das heißt, ich fordere die Größe auch an.
Du forderst auch die Größe an?
Aber dadurch......bekomme ich auch ein Piece nicht nur von einem anderen.
Genau, das ist genau der Punkt.
Sondern auch ein Piece bekomme ich von mehreren. Und die bekomme ich erstmal und in dem Moment, wo ich sie bekomme, kann ich sie ja noch gar nicht überprüfen. Weil als Einziges kann ich ja wirklich nur ein vollständiges Piece überprüfen. Das heißt, wenn da irgendwas falsch war, wenn ich von irgendeinem was Falsches bekommen habe...
Das hat seine Vorteile.
Kann es dann nicht sein, dass sich auch jemand jetzt irgendwie einklingt und sagt, okay, jetzt störe ich hier mal den Download und bietet massenhaft schadhafte Scheiße an, verteilt einfach kaputte Daten, sodass bei jedem die Pieces im Eimer sind? Dann kann man ja gar nicht feststellen, wer das ist.
Ja, die hängen sich damit rein. Von Firmen wie Media Defender oder Media Sentry oder sonst wie. Die connecten sich zu allen. Man sieht die auch gar nicht, weil die connecten kurz. Schicken dir einen so ein Ministück, nämlich 16 Kilobyte, defekt, und beenden danach die Connection auch gleich wieder und die sind weg. Und du legst dann die restlichen runter, die alle heile sind, und dann bastelst du zusammen, checkst die Größe mal. Nun, stimmt nicht.
Und deswegen willst du auch nicht, dass die Pieces zu groß sind, weil du dann sozusagen zu lange brauchst, um das Piece nochmal zusammenzuladen.
Kann man da was gegen tun?
Ja, da hab ich mir schon was dazu ausgedacht und hab es auch schon versucht, bei den kleinen Autoren zu verbreiten, aber die haben das noch nicht verstanden oder es ist denen auch zu komplex. Man kann natürlich sich einfach merken, von wem man welchen Block hat, und fängt dann an, die Checksumme drüber zu berechnen. Und wenn irgendwas nicht stimmt, dann lädt man halt nochmal den Piece herunter. Und wenn das wieder kaputt ist, dann kann man schon mal anfangen, diese Checksumme gleichzeitig über beide Blöcke zu berechnen und einfach an den Stellen, wo sich das unterscheidet, so einen Baum aufzumachen und dann zu gucken, ob man über irgendeinen der Wege zu einer korrekten Checksumme kommt.
Also man lädt die Blöcke mehrfach runter sozusagen. Und hat dann mehrere Möglichkeiten, den Hasch nochmal zu berechnen. Wenn bei der ersten Berechnung das nicht funktioniert, dann nimmt man den Ersatzblock und berechnet dann den Hasch nochmal.
Potentiell sogar herausfinden könnte, wer genau derjenige war, der ihm das geschickt hat.
Das ist aber auch nicht so viel, weil diese Firmen meistens sich so riesengroße Plätze und Reiche holen, mit irgendwie tausenden von Adressen, zum Beispiel 65.000 Adressen, und die jedes Mal mit einer anderen Adresse kommen. Man muss dann den ganzen Bereich irgendwie herausfinden, aber das wird schwierig. Man muss ja richtig manuell drauf gucken.
Und wenn man... Ist es denn, diese Kleins identifizieren sich doch auch? Also wenn ich mit einem anderen Peer spreche und der mir Daten schickt, dann weiß ich ja auch zum Beispiel, welches Programm da läuft. Die IP-Adresse, weiß ich nicht, gibt es da noch irgendwie andere Absenderdinger, an denen man den erkennen könnte? Die maskieren sich einfach als irgendein populärer Klein. Okay. Tja, das ist ja doof.
Meistens ist es sogar einer der populären Kleins, die sie einfach umgeschrieben haben. Also die sind da nicht zu faul, einfach mal Open-Source-Software zu benutzen und die umzuschreiben, um kaputte Daten zu verteilen.
Okay, gut. Also das ist nicht unangreifbar, aber trotzdem funktioniert es ja eigentlich relativ gut.
Das ist robust genug.
Das heißt, man müsste schon einen extremen Aufwand treiben, um das wirklich nachhaltig zu stören, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Nö, es reicht die Trekkertour zu machen.
Ah ja, das stimmt natürlich, weil genau, das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Das hatten wir ja schon vorher bei den Vorgängern. Die Frage ist immer, was ist so der Single Point of Failure? Was ist so das angreifbarste Subsystem? Kleinst gibt es bei Peer to Peer ohne Ende. Dem wird man sozusagen nicht wirklich her werden können, denke ich mal.
Das geht ja auch nicht mehr. So, der nächste, anderes Punkt sind halt die Trecker. Bei ML Donkey und so weiter waren es ja dicke Knotenpunkte, die wurden dann dicht gemacht und dann kamen nicht schnell genug neue hoch. Und bei BitTorrent ist es so, dass es halt z.B. nicht nur einen Trecker gibt, sondern es könnte hunderttausende geben. Und du kannst dir, wie du schon gesagt hast, hierfür deinen Trecker auswählen. Du musst halt keinen bestimmten nehmen. Jetzt könnten sie halt einen dicht machen. Dann würde jetzt vielleicht deine Datei nicht mehr funktionieren. Aber dann könnte man auch die Trecker-Adresse in dem Torrent verändern, ohne dass sich die Torrent-ID ändert. Und das einfach mit einem anderen Trecker weiter probieren. Oder man trägt gleich von vornherein mehrere Trecker ein. Das ist ein bisschen eine moderne Erweiterung. Und dann nutzt der Client einfach den nächsten Trecker auf der Liste, der irgendwie funktioniert.
Warum macht es denn überhaupt Sinn, den Trecker mit in diese Torrent-Datei einzutragen? Wäre es nicht viel sinnvoller, das einfach wegzulassen und dann testet man einfach alle durch und guckt, wo man die Datei findet?
Alle durch? Alle Trecker?
Das Problem dabei ist, dass...
Das ist ja nur ein HTTP-Request, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Nur ein HTTP-Request macht...
Dann musst du sagen, dass du eine Liste von allen haben. Und wo willst du die Liste von allen her haben? Du kannst jetzt alle IP-Adressen mit allen Ports ausprobieren, aber das ist ein bisschen viel.
Nein, man könnte ja so... Ja, genau, also was dachte ich?
Das ist schon okay, wenn das einfach in dem Torrent drin steht, den du dann auch verteilst, kannst du dafür sorgen, dass da genug drinstehen, die halt nicht schnell genug nicht gemacht werden. Das Problem bei vielen Trackern ist natürlich, dass diese Wolke von Leuten, die da entsteht, die an einer Datei interessiert sind, dann aufgeteilt wird in Leuten, die sich beim einen oder anderen Tracker anmelden. Das ist dann halt der Nachteil davon, mehrere Trackern zu benutzen.
Okay, so, jetzt versuche ich nochmal kurz, damit wir die Sache im Blick halten, spule ich nochmal so ein bisschen kurz zurück, weil es ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema, wo man irgendwie schnell Überblick verlieren kann. Ich habe mir auch irgendwann mal diesen Vortrag von diesem Bram Cohn, der mal im Internet veröffentlicht wurde, angeschaut, wo er einzelne Aspekte des BitTorrent-Protokolls geredet hat. Zum Beispiel, warum braucht man überhaupt Checksummen? Man könnte ja davon ausgehen, wieso wir benutzen auch alle Protokolle, die selber Checksummen haben. Er meinte einfach, die Realität im Internet ist einfach anders. Daten gehen einfach kaputt, während sie übertragen werden. Es gibt viele Router, die einfach in die Pakete reingehen, Nut-Systeme, an die auch noch mal was zu sagen.
Es ist ein Wunder, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Genau, es ist ein Wunder. Insofern ist BitTorrent auch relativ gehärtet. So gegen die Realität, das ist ja ganz offensichtlich. Weil das alles so kompliziert ist, fasse ich noch mal kurz zusammen. Wir haben bei BitTorrent eine Struktur, die besteht aus den Piers, die einfach was verteilen wollen. Die benutzen diesen BitTorrent Client, oder einen von mehreren BitTorrent Clients. Dann finden sie zueinander über den Tracker. Nachdem sie zueinander gefunden haben, geht die Kommunikation eigentlich nur noch von Pier zu Pier. Pier-to-Pier eben genauso, wie das Name sagt.
Sie fragen regelmäßig beim Tracker nach und sagen, ich lebe noch, weil üblicherweise ist Konvention, dass nach 45-60 Minuten der Tracker einen Pier wieder austrägt.
Weil man sich ja nicht automatisch abmeldet, sondern man timet sozusagen aus. Nach dem Motto, du hast ihn nicht gemeldet, also tschüss. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ein Tracker stirbt, stirbt dann auch irgendwann die Übertragung dieser Datei? Pier kann einfach weiterlaufen. Solange wir unsere Konvention halten. Wenn sie sich einmal gefunden haben, es ist Partnervermittlung. Aber wie lange reden denn dann die Pier so miteinander? Also die reden ja auch nicht ewig miteinander, oder?
Wir gucken erstmal auf gegenseitiges Interesse. Wenn wir zum Beispiel zwei Cedar sehen, die beide alles haben.
Also ein Cedar ist einer, der alles hat? Und ein Leecher heißt, glaube ich, jemand, der... Der hat weniger als alles. Okay, es gibt Cedar und Leecher.
Es gibt noch Leute, die Leecher als Schimpfwort für jemanden benutzen, der seine Upload-Ratio so weit runtergedrosselt hat, dass er niemandem was anbietet, was er reinbekommt. Aber das soll ja Protokoll im Moment verboten sein. Aber eigentlich gibt es wirklich PS, die entweder Cedar oder Leecher sind.
Gut, das haben wir festgehalten. Und so, wenn ich jetzt Cedar bin, verhalte ich mich anders?
Außer andere Cedar, die dann diese Connections zu dir machen, die lösen deine Leiche auf, weil die wollen nichts von dir, du willst nichts von denen, und dann braucht man keine Verbindung.
Also eigentlich ist... Die könnte aber auch gelogen sein. Aber die Piers untereinander sprechen wie mit ganz einfachen Paketen miteinander. Die schicken ein Paket rüber, pingen, ich lebe noch. Die schicken rüber, pingen, ich habe gerade einen neuen Peace vollständig bekommen, den ich auch gecheckt habe. Sie sagen, ich hätte gerne von dir das und das. Und dann kommen noch Pakete, in denen wirklich Daten drin stehen. Und das war's.
Warum sollte ich denn eigentlich, ich meine, dieses Peer-to-Peer basiert ja auch so ein bisschen auf Goodwill. Also ich meine, ich müsste ja jetzt niemanden was schicken, oder? Die machen dir dann auch nichts. Das heißt, die Kleinen sind so programmiert, dass man eigentlich nur dem was schickt, der einem auch selber was schickt?
Nee, na nicht nur. Du siehst auch zum Beispiel das Pieces, die nur einer deiner Neighbors hatte. Und jetzt plötzlich ein anderer deiner Neighbors auch. Piers, Entschuldigung.
Beer to Beer, ja genau. Du hast sozusagen von vornherein den Podcast. Was hast du da angeschleppt? Augustina Breu München. Lagerbier Hell.
Prenzlberger Bier.
Mein Gott. Du machst aus Chaosradio Express ein Dignation-Podcast. Ist das überhaupt klar?
Das tut mir ganz doll leid. Es ist nur, dass unsere Software unter der Bierwehr-Lizenz veröffentlicht worden ist und ich jetzt endlich mal die Bierwehr-Lizenz beim Cryx einlösen musste, der für mich Teile der Software auch geschrieben hat. Und dann diese Lizenz veröffentlicht.
Auf die Software kommen wir ja gleich noch zu sprechen. Wir enthalten ja nichts vor.
Genau, aber wir waren bei den Piers, die jetzt gerade rausfinden wollten, wer denn fair ist und auch den anderen Piers Daten schickt. Also erstens kriegt man natürlich selber mit, ob man von seinen Nachbarn Pieces bekommen hat.
Das ist schon wieder bei den Nachbarn. Was ist denn für dich ein Nachbar?
Na, es ist ein Pier. Also Nachbar ist ja das deutsche Wort für Pier in dem Moment.
Ah, okay, also du sagst Nachbar, wenn du eigentlich Pier sagen willst. Und weil es dann aber cooler klingt, sagst du trotzdem Neighbor.
Das allerdings liegt wieder am Pier.
Du bist so ein lites Hacker-Kid, glaube ich.
Krass, was? Okay, also man sieht, welche Piers...
Leider den Piers, ich finde das ein schönes Wort.
Welche Piers einem Pakete schicken, sieht man ja. Also wenn man von den Piers es bekommt, dann ist der schon mal prima. Wenn ein anderer Pier als Einziger in seiner Nachbarschaft ein bestimmtes Pies hatte und es hat plötzlich ein anderer Pier dasselbe Pies, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass der das von dem bekommen hat, dann kannst du den auch als Positiv bewerten, weil der hat schon mal geteilt.
Was definierst du denn als Nachbarschaft?
Die Nachbarschaft sind gerade die Piers, mit denen du dich im Moment verbunden hast. Eine Peer-Group.
Erdgeist, du kriegst deine Begriffe heute nicht durch. Das hat keinen Sinn.
Eigentlich heißt es ja Wolke. Also alle, die gerade...
Wolke, Schwarm, Nachbarschaft, Peer-Group.
Man ist ja, selbst wenn man vom Trecker Tausende von potentiellen Piers bekommt, verbindet man sich in Wirklichkeit nie mehr als mit 10-20 Piers. Weil ansonsten die Nachrichten, die man mit seinen Piers austauschen müsste, sonst die gesamte Leitung zumachen würde, wenn man nicht mehr dazu käme, Daten auszutauschen.
Okay, das ist doch wertvoll, dass man das noch mal festhält. Also in dem Moment, wo ich mich vom Trecker vermitteln lasse, schickt er mir alles, was er weiß.
Na ja, also der Trecker möchte...
Okay, das heißt, ich schränke von vornherein ein. Mehr als 50 brauche ich nicht zu sehen.
Der Trecker hat auch seine Worte, damit er nicht unendlich Adressen übermittelt. Die wollen ja nicht riesengroße Pakete schicken. Am besten ein kleines Paket passen.
Okay, weil es kann ja sein, dass da wirklich gerade 50.000 Leute an so einer Datei rumnagen.
Das ist nicht unwahrscheinlich.
Und diese Auswahl ist dann zufällig? Oder optimieren die auf Basis von IP-Adressen?
Man könnte ja denken, okay, das ist jetzt ein Typ, der in seiner Riesenfirma saugt, die ein Riesennetz haben, und jetzt gebe ich ihm auch nur andere Leute in seiner Firma, die auch in diesem Riesennetz sind, damit die schneller untereinander austauschen könnten, was ja stimmen würde. Das Problem ist nur, wenn die alle nichts haben, dann ist ihnen ja nicht geholfen. Deswegen muss man den Leuten ja von außerhalb geben. Also am besten weltweit randommäßig verteilen.
Also man kann da bestimmt beliebig teure Heuristiken drauf machen, auf welche Daten man da hat, aber am Ende muss man halt hunderttausende Torrents verwalten, die Millionen von Peers haben und darauf groß Data-Mining zu machen, um raus zu finden.
Es ist wahrscheinlich auch unklug, zu versuchen, da irgendeine Intelligenz drauf zu werfen.
Du bist nicht cleverer als ich. Man könnte jetzt sagen, nur dieses Land sieht sich untereinander. Das könnte man tun, dann wäre es schön, weil z.B. in China keine Informationen nach draußen gehen würden. Aber das will man ja vielleicht auch gar nicht.
China-Drecker darauf.
Ja, dass die Informationen sich möglichst breitflächig und schnell verteilen. Und deswegen ist es nicht schlau, Wolken zu schaffen oder Peer-Groups.
Okay, also obwohl man da theoretisch eine Policy machen könnte, tun das die Trecker normalerweise nicht. Zumindest nicht nach unserem Wissen. Okay, das heißt jetzt bekomme ich diesen zufälligen Subset von 50 Peers, aber auch die spreche ich nicht alle an.
Na, 20 macht Sinn so ungefähr. Man kann sich das aussuchen.
Okay, das heißt einen nach dem anderen frage ich an und sage, hallo, ich habe gehört, du hast auch Daten. Sag mir doch mal, welche du hast.
Nein, wirklich klappt es sich eher so aus, dass du erst mal dahin gehst und versuchst eine Verbindung aufzubauen und in 90% der Fälle geht das eh schief, weil die sich als DSL-Kunde irgendwo hinter einem Router befinden, der auch noch...
Und dann haben wir wieder das Nutt-Problem.
Da haben wir dann das Nutt-Problem.
Wo das schon häufiger ist, aber an dieser Stelle auch noch mal besonders wichtig, man kann das ja auch gerne nochmal wiederholen, ist halt das Problem, dass einfach 99% aller Leute, die so am Internet hängen, kriegen halt nicht beliebig viele IP-Adressen, sondern eben nur eine. Und deswegen muss man die quasi multiplexen. Das heißt, der Router, den man hat, diese kleine Plaste-Box, die kriegt die Adresse vom Netz. Und alle Rechner, die dahinter sind, auch wenn es nur einer ist, sind sozusagen verborgen, benutzen so interne Sachen mit 10 oder mit 192, 68. Jeder hat das schon mal gesehen. Und das Problem ist, dass man dann eben nicht von außen erreichbar ist. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ein anderer Kleid mich ansprechen will, bleibt er bei meinem Gateway hängen. Genau. Was kann man dagegen tun?
Wenn du ihn ansprechen willst, kommst du in der Audition durch, weil du das gleiche Problem hast. Das heißt, ihr beide könnt euch gar nicht sehen.
Königskinder sozusagen.
Man braucht einen, der Kollektionsabhängen kann, damit man über den Land austauschen kann. Beide, die sich selber nicht sehen können, könnten über einen Dritten, der sichtbar ist, ihre Sachen aufnehmen.
Man kann andererseits auch auf dem Plastorouter, den man hatte, in einem der üblichen Konfigurationsfenster, den Port, der von draußen nach drinnen weitergeleitet werden soll, einfach freischalten. Dann klappt es auch mit dem Nachbarn.
Mein Computer hat Adresse XY und wenn jetzt über diesen Port was rankommt, dann bitte an diesen Rechner weiter reiten. Das ist so der Klassiker. Ich bin ja......der einen Selbstaufmachtzeit-UPnP. Ja, die finde ich ja total toll. Soll ich sie nochmal erwähnen?
Ich habe es versucht zu implementieren. Das ist ein Bane in the S, hat sich Microsoft ausgedacht.
UPnP ist furchtbar, aber hast du schon mal NatpnP ausprobiert?
Ich weiß, das ist alles nicht schönes.
Nein, das ist total toll. Das sind irgendwie zwei ODP-Pakete, die du schicken musst. NatpnP, das macht Apple. Das sind in allen Airports drin. Es gibt auch einen Open Source Code, kommt hier aus Wien, aus dem MetaLab. Letzte Vorleser der Chaosradio Express-Sendung. Hat da irgendjemand gehackert. Ist nämlich ganz einfach. Du sagst einfach dem Gateway, hallo Gateway, sag mir mal deine externe IP-Adresse. Dann sagt er, meine externe IP-Adresse ist... Und dann sagst du, ich hätte aber gerne mal den Port sowieso. Kannst du mir den mal freischalten? Dann schaltet er den frei und dann sagt er, du bist jetzt zu erreichen unter sowieso. Genau das, was man haben kann.
Das ist ja auch kein Rock'n'Science eigentlich.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Es gibt natürlich auch... Also hier mein BitTorrent-Fleid macht das hier, der Transmission. Der sagt irgendwie, Router, hallo, und der spricht dann... Genau. Ja, ich auch. Wir wollen das im Klopapier. Hier funktioniert das wunderbar.
Wir driften ab, wir wollten ja jetzt schauen.
Nee, aber das ist echt ein wichtiges Problem, weil wenn man nicht von außen erreichbar ist, dann kann man den Leuten nichts bieten.
Weil man dann halt einfach jemanden benutzen muss, der dann halt wieder als...
Man kann ihm nur was bieten, wenn er meine Anfrage angenommen hat. Aber er kann mich nicht ansprechen. Das dauert einfach länger.
Man kann ja nur Leute ansprechen, die einen Port offen haben. Da sitzen viele hinter einem Latt. Das heißt, die Leute, die einen Port offen haben, sind ja überrannt. Deswegen will man möglichst auch einer sein, der Port offen hat, damit man auch überrannt.
Man hat natürlich immer die Konkurrenz für alle anderen, die sich bei demselben Pier verbunden haben. Bei der muss man sich ja auch entscheiden, wem seine Upload-Bandbreite zur Verfügung stellt. Die ist meistens viel geringer als die Download-Bandbreite. Und in so einem Pier-to-Pier-Netz kann man ganz einfach ausrechnen, dass alles, was sich herunterladen kann, also was alle Pier herunterladen können, nicht mehr sein kann, als alles, was alle Pier hochladen können. Ganz einfach Rechnung. Und somit...
Was war jetzt eine einfache Rechnung?
Du kannst nicht mehr runterladen in deiner Wolke, als du hochladen kannst.
Okay, ich kann nicht mehr runterladen, als ich hochladen kann.
Aber ich kann immer mehr runterladen, als ich hochlade. In der Summe von allen Pier, die miteinander sprechen...
In der Summe ist das ja auch ein und dasselbe.
Jetzt wird es zu philosophisch. Das ist die gleiche Zahl. Wenn du nur DSL-Kunden hast, dann wird die Gesamt-Download-Geschwindigkeit nicht höher sein für die einzelnen im Durchschnitt, als die Upload-Geschwindigkeit von den DSL-Kunden.
Okay, wer diesen Satz verstanden hat, schickt eine E-Mail an chaosradioxccc.de, eure Gelegenheit, Feedback zu geben und uns zu sagen, ob wir eigentlich hier noch verständliches Zeug reden. Ist natürlich jetzt auch ein komplexes Thema und spätestens zu diesem Zeitpunkt durften sich einige Leute aus dem Podcast ausgeklinkt haben, die gedacht haben, dass wir hier einfach mal nur so ein bisschen über Falschsharing sinnieren. Tun wir nicht, sondern wir gehen ja ins Eingemachte und versuchen mal, die Sache genau zu erklären. Was versuchst du jetzt gerade mit Tacker, die Bierflasche zu öffnen? Es geht. Ja, es geht. Hacker, ein richtiger Hacker. Da klappt es auch mit dem Tacker.
Dann karlauerten sie sich durch den Abendbrust.
Ich wusste schon, dass es eine sehr joviale Sendung wird.
Jetzt hat er ein Open-Bier.
Willkommen bei Dignation Express. Jetzt auch mit Bierflaschen. Nur, Denis... Ja, das kann ich machen. Ich kann dir eine Mate geben. Wenn ich nicht wieder vergesse, danach die Mikrofone einzuschalten. Aber ich habe überhaupt keine Musik. Du kannst ja einfach selber eine holen. Du brauchst dann nur...
Jetzt ist Tims Wohnung im Podcast.
Aber ich habe keine... Ja, da gehst du raus und da immer geradeaus. Und da ist dann keine Mate im Kühlschrank.
Wir haben ja leider keine Bluetooth-Hatze, deswegen...
Das ist noch eine kalte Mate, die steht noch draußen. Die ist halb voll. Die habe ich nur vorhin für den Cocktail benutzt. Okay, Denis, wir sehen dich. Bis bald. So, na dann können wir jetzt mal endlich über die wichtigen Sachen reden.
Wo waren wir denn jetzt gerade? Ach so, wir hatten die 90 Prozent, die ich weiter in meiner Bombe beißte.
Wir reden jetzt über Denis. Okay, möchtest du noch einen komplexen Sachverhalt?
Wir waren ja jetzt gerade dabei gewesen vor dem Natt, dass man, wenn man die Liste vom Trecker abgekommen hat, sich jetzt versucht bei allen Peels mal zu verbinden. Und sind dann darauf gekommen, dass es bei vielen schon nicht klappt, wegen des Nattes, hinter dem sie sich verstecken.
Genau, Natt ist einfach ein Problem und es ist scheiße und es stinkt, aber es ist überall und deswegen muss man was dagegen tun.
Weil es nur so wenig IP-Adressen auf der Welt gibt.
Weil es nur so wenig angeblich so wenig IP-Adressen gibt.
Wenn alle Chinesen eine wollen, dann ist bald eng. IPv4-Adresse. Der Trecker kann eh keine IPv6.
Okay, Denis hat mittlerweile die Mate geschnappt. Jetzt können wir auf gleicher Augenhöhe weiter diskutieren. So, die... Gott, wo waren wir denn jetzt gerade? Ach ja, genau, wir haben besprochen, wie wählt sich jetzt der Kleine eigentlich so seine Partner aus. Das heißt, ihr kriegt eine Liste von Adressen vom Trecker. Dann spricht er die irgendwie alle an und versucht zu ermitteln, wer für einen jetzt irgendwie wertvoll ist. Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass sie sich immer alle gegenseitig ansprechen können, dass diese Nat-Problematik von gestern ist. Geht eigentlich BitTorrent auch über IPv6? Gibt es irgendwie Kleinstil mit IPv6-Arbeiten?
Ja, es gab damals Versuche.
Alle?
Also, man am Ende ist es halt, du machst eine Verbindung zu irgendwas auf, was du vom Trecker bekommst. Der Trecker kann eigentlich auch V6-Adressen, aber...
Was heißt denn eigentlich?
Ja, die Original Implementation war die Adresse als Text. Das wurde aber abgeschafft, weil das zu viel war.
Da passt natürlich IPv6 nicht rein. Aber theoretisch ist es...
Also, das Protokoll hatte V6 mit dabei, aber schlecht.
Das Protokoll ist ein bisschen bekloppt, was man mit dem Trecker spricht. Da ist sozusagen IPv4 fest codiert, sodass man nicht so ohne weiteres wieder auf V6 geht.
Nein, IPv6 wird bestraft. Das ist das Problem. Im Protokoll ist IPv4 schön performant implementiert und festgeschrieben, aber IPv6 wird bestraft, indem deine Pakete plötzlich 30-mal so groß werden.
30-mal so groß?
Im Endeffekt ist es egal, ob es IPv6 oder IPv4 ist. Da steht in dem Torrentfall eine Adresse drin, wie dein Client dahin connectet, ob es bei IPv4 oder IPv6 ist.
Theoretisch müsste es irgendwie gehen. Wenn man IPv6 zu Hause hat, auf welche Art und Weise auch immer, dann sieht es unter Umständen schon besser aus.
Du brauchst dann Heuristiken, wem du welche Adressen rausgibst. Ob du V6-Piers nur V6-Adressen gibst oder V4-Piers nur V6-Adressen gibst.
Das ist genau das gleiche Transition-Problem, das wir jetzt mit IPv6 auch haben.
It's horrible.
Einfach mal ausschalten, auf V6 umstellen, wieder anschalten.
Das heißt, der Normalzustand ist, wenn der Kleine anfängt, seine Arme auszustrecken, die Muskeln zu entspannen ist, wenn er einfach so seinen Set von Piers hat, seine Nachbarschaft, seine Peergroup, seine Freunde, seine Jungs. Seine Hood.
Genau, und dann plappern die miteinander.
Das geht gar nicht los hier.
Ja.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum, weil der BitTorrent-Kleid hat erst mal selber noch nichts da. Und dann sind die anderen natürlich auch erst mal noch nicht so richtig bereit, ich weiß nicht alle, sind auch Pieces oder Teile davon rüber zu schieben. Deswegen muss man ein bisschen warten, weil so ein paar Pakete kommen irgendwann und dann hat man auch irgendwann sein erstes Piece komplett. Und dann, wenn das erste Piece da ist, dann kann man ja auch zum allerersten Mal überhaupt selber ausliefern. Das heißt, dann fängt man zum ersten Mal selber Sachen rauszuschicken. Und dann merken wiederum die anderen da draußen, aha, der hat mir ja was gegeben, ist ja gar nicht so schlecht, dann geb ich dem jetzt auch mal was dadurch, kriegt man wieder schneller Zeug rein, das schaue ich sich langsam hoch und schon ist man mitten im Geschäft.
Naja, das heißt, umso mehr man hat, umso mehr...
Du weißt, die ersten 1-2-3% ist immer langsam bei BitTorrent, da passiert ja schon allzu viel.
Also viel in der richtigen Jugendgruppe, in dem Moment, wo man auch ein bisschen was zu bieten hat und so, was zu tauschen hat. Oder Panini, Fußballbildchen irgendwie. Ich brauch dann erstmal so irgendwie die Nationalmannschaft komplett und so und dann krieg ich auch.
Also sie haben das dann auch so implementiert, dass es halt in der Protokollspezifikation gerade dafür gesagt wird, mach auch, selbst wenn er dir nichts schickt und wie gerade wie eine Sau aussieht, kann es ja auch einfach sein, dass er noch nichts hat. Also schick ihm erstmal was und guck, wie er sich dann verhält. Und na halt bei den ersten paar Blöcken wird er noch nichts machen können und dann geht man wieder weg und dann kommt der nächste, macht genau dasselbe und irgendwann hat er dann wirklich genug Blöcke.
Das macht man auch ziemlich ähnlich, wenn einer nichts schickt, irgendwann schickt man ihn nicht mehr. Weil die Kleinen sind auch so geschmieden, dass man möglichst viel rausschicken will. Weil es ist ja für alle hilfreich, wenn man viel rausschickt und dann einer zum Beispiel auch nicht genug annimmt, also wenn er nicht genug Incoming hat, dann sucht man sicher noch andere dazu, dass man denen viel schickt.
Wie gut ist denn das BitTorrent-Protokoll eigentlich dokumentiert?
Doch, schon ganz gut. Also es gibt da halt einen Wiki. Wenn man einfach BitTorrent-Wiki in Google eingebt, dann kommt da die Protokollspezifikation, die ist sehr gut dokumentiert, die ist von Entwicklern von Clients auch noch kommentiert. So wie sie sich da mit dem Kram jetzt gedacht haben, der in der Dokumentation drin steht und wenn man sich das durchgelesen hat, dann kann man eigentlich schon einen kleinen bauen. Die ist wirklich prima.
Hast du da eine URL gerade mal im Kopf irgendwie?
Die können wir bestimmt nachher in den Podcast reintun, im Kopf habe ich sie nicht. Also das ist wie, glaube ich, wikitheory.org oder so.
Jaja, das habe ich. Okay, ja, wiki.theory.org, richtig, BitTorrent-Spezifikation, alles klar, okay, wusste ich nicht, dass es das gibt, aber offensichtlich gibt es das. Und du meinst, dass es ausreichend beschrieben ist, dass auch alle Clients dann sich weitgehend gleichmäßig verhalten? Es sind noch diverse, also es gibt ja verschiedene, vielleicht sollten wir mal ein bisschen auf die Clients eingehen. Es gibt ja so den Ur-Client, eben den BitTorrent von bittorrent.com von Bram Cohn selber gehackt, wie du schon gesagt hast, in Python geschrieben. Was auch den Vorteil hat, lässt sich natürlich auch super in Programme embedden, so, es gibt ja auch schon mittlerweile viele Programme, die so, bei Python kann man halt ganz gut embedden, so, also das muss man natürlich auch irgendwie erst mal hinkriegen, aber das geht auf jeden Fall, es gibt ja auch Browser, die schon BitTorrent-Support haben, Opera zum Beispiel, oder es ist nur Opera, ich weiß es gar nicht, und so, aber dann kam ja dann relativ zügig, nachdem sich BitTorrent erst mal so halbwegs popularisiert hat, andere Clients raus und wenn man heute mal so schaut hier in seine Statistiken, wie wenn man irgendwas überträgt, sieht man ja, dass eigentlich BitTorrent selber fast überhaupt nicht mehr dabei ist.
Das liegt daran, dass der Client selber eine ziemlich ineffiziente Strategie hat, die Blöcke, die er reinbekommt, auf die Festplatte zu speichern. Und damit kopiert das ständig hin und her, die Festplatte sind nur am rödeln und hast du dann plötzlich deine Festplatte als Limit und deswegen hat da keiner mehr Bock drauf.
Okay, das heißt, der ist nicht bunt genug.
Und der ist nicht bunt genug. Das ist aber ein bisschen bunter gewesen. Also ich gucke hier gerade mal, was haben wir denn hier. Hier gibt es irgendwie Mikrotorrent, Bitlord, Bitkomet. Naja, er versucht sich da auf jeden Fall ein bisschen...
Und die haben dann eine BitTorrent-Kleinzahl aufgekauft, nämlich den Mikrotorrent. Und der andere BitTorrent-Klein ist der Azurias. Die wurden auch irgendwann von so einem Konsortium oder so, ich weiß nicht was genau, wurden auch aufgekauft. Das heißt, da sind jetzt schon auch sehr stark kommerzielle Interessen.
Worin unterscheiden sich die Kleins, außer in den Programmiersprachen? Du hast ja auch gesagt, es gibt auch unterschiedliche Strategien, wie die Detail auf die Platte geschrieben werden.
Aber man merkt schon, wenn es nicht so doll performt, aber andererseits ist es halt, sie übertreffen sich dann wirklich nur in einer leichten Bedienbarkeit, wie man selber Torrents machen kann. Ob das eikenlustig ist oder ein giftiger Frosch oder Natraversel eingebaut ist. Dann gibt es noch einzelne Files aussuchen, dann gibt es noch...
Ja, weil wenn man sich so eine riesige DVD zieht und man will eigentlich nur...
Dann fragst du deine Piers einfach nur nach den Blöcken, die halt zu den Dateien gehören, die dich...
Ist man dann irgendwie benachteiligt so im Download-Prozess?
Du kannst die Blöcke von diesem Stück, den du nicht haben willst, natürlich auch nicht rausschieben und hast dadurch nichts im Angebot.
Ist nicht wirklich dramatisch.
Aber wenn ich was nicht haben will, dann heißt das, dass man Client auch gar nicht erst danach fragt und dass mir das also auch nie einer schickt.
Richtig.
So, und welche Clients sind so eure Favoriten, was benutzt ihr?
Ich habe früher sehr viel den BitTorrent-Command Line gespielt, und bin dann mal eine Weile gewechselt auf BitTorrent-Marge, was meine Erweiterung nach muss, also gleiche Code, aber verbessert. Und das war dann aber immer noch nicht mehr toll, weil BitTorrent war auch ein bisschen langsam und irgendwie riesengroß und Gigabyte zu DVDs und so, den man ja auch nicht immer wieder durchchecken müsste, weil der BitTorrent-Client muss ja auch wieder nochmal durchchecken, danach neu starten, ob noch alles da ist oder nicht, weil es können sie sich ja verändert haben. So sind wir jetzt langsam und deswegen benutze ich jetzt schon seit einer Weile auf dem Mac den Transmission-Client.
Ich habe früher den Original-Python-Kram benutzt, glaube ich, und dann habe ich mal kurz X-Torrent getestet. Und dann habe ich vorher Transmission benutzt, dann habe ich kurz X-Torrent benutzt und das ist aber jetzt irgendwie Kaufsoftware und dann bin ich wieder zurück zu Transmission und benutze da jetzt eigentlich immer das, was gerade im SVN drin ist. Ich falsch jahre gar nicht.
Achso, du machst das geil, du checkst mal.
Ich lade nur Tims Homebound runter, Wikipedia, FreeBSD und ja.
Na klar, ich meine, das mache ich auch nur. Also wir scherzen so ein bisschen, aber es ist ja auch tatsächlich, es wird ja viel darüber diskutiert, so ist BitTorrent jetzt irgendwie generell böse, weil irgendwie benutzt man, wenn man falsche Sachen benutzt, heißt das dann automatisch, dass man sich illegalen Aktivitäten...
Na ein sicherer Indikator dafür ist schon, dass Microsoft, als sie gesehen hat, dass es eine tolle Idee ist, selber versucht hat, dieses Protokoll noch mal unter eigenem Namen herauszubringen, mit ein paar Modifikationen, einen Protokollspezifikationen hat sie......
den wir schon alle vergessen haben.
Avalanche hieß das raus.
Avalanche, genau, ja.
Und das ist schon so ein Indikator, dass es halt eine prima Idee ist.
Ich dachte, wenn man die Paar-Industrie benutzt, wäre es eine prima Idee.
Also Microsoft-Techniker sind dafür bezahlt worden, ein bisschen zu philosophieren, was man mal will.
Aber wenn Microsoft diese Idee schon mal grundsätzlich prima findet, dann kann es ja nicht nur illegal sein.
Aber das ist ja was, was wir auch in Bram Cohn gesehen haben, dass man nicht nur Ideen haben muss. Weil ich habe mir früher auch schon gedacht, so verteilt und so, dass jeder was rausschiebt, was man so hat, könnte man ja mal abhalten. Aber es gibt schon mal eine Nachfrage. Aber Bram Cohn hat halt sich hingesetzt und das getan.
Aber das ist also das Gleiche, was wir vorhin schon mal hatten. Mit den PIA-Adressen, ob die jetzt illegaler Dateien hinschieben oder nicht. Die Teilnahme an Fall-Sharing, ist das jetzt was Illegales oder nicht? Wenn man sich jetzt sozusagen anguckt, dass die Wikipedia ihre DVD per BitTorrent verteilt und Word of Warcraft die Updates per BitTorrent verteilt, oder FreeBSD oder wie sie alle heißen, dann muss man sich fragen, warum die ISPs jetzt dazu übergegangen sind, BitTorrent-User wirklich runterzushapen, also ihre Bandbreite zu begrenzen und ganz aktiv das Protokoll zu behindern. In Amerika gibt es da einen, weiß gar nicht mehr, wie er heißt, irgendein ISP, der macht das Comcast, glaube ich, heißt der, und der macht das wirklich massiv und da beschweren sich auch alle darüber.
Das ist eigentlich eine super Methode, seine Kunden loszuwerden.
Ja, das ist eigentlich eine super Methode, ja.
Weil, wenn man bedenkt, dass irgendwie 80 Prozent des Treffes BitTorrent ist...
Es ist auch total braindead, weil die Leute kaufen sich Internet, um BitTorrent zu machen und Falscharing, und dann machen die ISPs ihnen Falscharing aus, weil sie... Mischkalkulatieren. Sie wollen halt nicht, dass die Leute Internet benutzen.
In Hollywood, in dieses BitTorrent von Brian Cohn da rein investiert, verteilen die ja ihre Filme, da hat ja auch noch eine Webseite, wo man auch Filme runterladen kann, es geht ja auch über BitTorrent, und es ist ja auch ein legitimer Ansatz, und da sieht man ja schon, dass das auch legal und auch legal zu kommerziellen Zwecke händeln, wie gesagt, bei World of Warcraft, da sind nicht so viele User, und die Updates sind auch teilweise nicht frei. Das geht eben nicht. Mit BitTorrent, du kannst ja für einen Tracker, lassen wir ja schon von hatten, einen Port aussuchen, also jeder Tracker könnte auf einem anderen Port liegen, und deswegen gibt es da keine festen Portflieger, die man nicht sperren könnte. Bei Web könnte man jetzt noch Port 80 sperren, da kann man natürlich auch seine Webseite auf einen anderen Port legen, aber mit BitTorrent ist es wirklich total egal, man kriegt davon auch gar nichts.
Und die Kleins untereinander, die suchen sich auch irgendwelche Ports aus, denen sie erreichbar sind.
Kann man aber trotzdem filtern, das tun die Leute.
Na gut, im traditionellen BitTorrent-Protokoll fingen dieses Paket, das erste Paket, auch wirklich schön an, mit immer derselben Folge, da standen die BitTorrent-Protokoll-Versionen drin, konnte man einfach ziemlich leicht in Hardware sogar danach suchen, und die Pakete wegwerfen, und damit BitTorrent totmachen, wenn einem das nicht gefallen hat. Inzwischen haben sie sich aber ausgedacht, dass man ja auch so eine Verschlüsselung rudimentär einfach mal dazu zuklicken kann. Und die BitTorrent-Clients können jetzt eigentlich fast alle entkryptet...
Was wird dann verschlüsselt?
Die gesamte Verbindung.
Das heißt, die vollständige...
Peer-to-Peer-Font...
.Kommunikation zwischen den Peers ist verschlüsselt, sodass keinem... dem vollständigen Datentraffic nicht mehr anzusehen ist, worum es da geht.
Genau. Und die Schlüssel benutzen sie einfach den Hash. Also die Torrent-ID. Die Torrent-ID. Also wir hatten ja gesagt, dass so ein Torrent identifiziert wird über den Hash, über die Checksumme, die über das gesamte Torrent-Pfeil.
Warum nimmt man nicht den Hash von der Checksumme, von dem einzelnen Piece?
Weil man ja über eine Connection mehrere Pieces austauschen kann. Wo es sogar was, haben wir auch noch nicht erwähnt, man kann ja über eine Connection sogar Pieces von verschiedenen Torrent-IDs austauschen. Das war früher mal nicht. Der Brian Cone hat das schon mal vorgesehen, aber nicht implementiert. Deswegen gab es früher pro Torrent-ID, hat da glaube ich immer sogar einen eigenen Port aufgemacht oder so. Und inzwischen geht das aber alles über einen und gleichen Port. Dann unterscheiden für welches Torrent es denn ist. Dann ist die Verschlüsselung dann...
Ich hab da auch noch nichts von gehört, bin gerade irgendwie ganz interessant an dir zu hören. Weil eigentlich passiert immer noch genau dasselbe für jedes. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht streiten, wenn du meinst.
Über den kommen sie alle rein.
Ja, also ich kann auch nur einen einzigen Port bei mir.
Ja, ja schon, aber der Endpunkt von dems aus geht es in andere.
Ist das eigentlich TCP oder UDP?
Das ist TCP.
Das heißt, über dieselben Port können auch mehrere Connections gemacht werden. Das ist das wahrscheinlich, was du meinst. Aber dann müsste ja in der Connection, wenn die gesamte Connection verschlüsselt ist...
Ja, nicht nur, dass du auch in dem Protokoll, die die Pakete untereinander austauschen, steht nicht mehr drin, welchen Torrent hast du meinst, also welchen Torrent du meinst, sondern einfach nur noch du sagst, welchen Piers sind welche.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die Piers sich miteinander kommunizieren, verschlüsselt, müssen sie eigentlich schon wissen, warum sie eigentlich sich miteinander verbinden. Also dann müssen sie ja sozusagen schon beide wissen, dass es jetzt um genau diesen einen Torrent geht. Und wenn die jetzt mehrere...
Ja, aber ich habe da auch noch nichts von gehört. Müssen wir noch mal nachgucken.
Ja, aber wenn man jetzt den Hash von dem Torrent nimmt, woher soll denn ein Client, der jetzt eine Verbindung annimmt, wissen, um welchen Torrent das geht? Also woher soll er dann überhaupt wissen, welche Verschlüsselung da gerade verwendet wird?
Vielleicht benutzen wir zur Initialisierung erst mal was, was nicht inkribiert ist?
Also die Verschlüsselung, die benutzt wird, ist RC4. Und die hat halt mehrere bekannte Schwächen. Die kann man dadurch ausbügeln, dass man am Anfang einmal 1024 Byte wirklich random schickt, was auch dazu hilft, dass man nicht so leicht entdeckt wird.
Und die haben sich das mal einfallen lassen. Und dann waren sie aber nicht ganz so doof und haben dann mal einen Experten rüberschauen lassen. Und der hat gesagt, ja, das ist zwar alles ganz nett, aber wenn am Anfang immer das gleiche Verschlüssel übertragen wird, dann kann man relativ schnell rausfinden, was es ist.
Sogenannte Plain-Tex-Attacker, ja.
Deswegen hat er gesagt, schickt erst mal ein Kilobyte random Take darüber, damit das eben nicht geht. Und das ist das, was die Erdgeist-Karriere erwähnen.
Aber das eigentliche Problem haben wir jetzt noch nicht gelöst. Okay, also wir wissen auch nicht alles. Das ist doch schon mal ganz gut. Genau, also falls ihr irgendwas besser wisst...
Schön, dass wir eine Podiumsdiskussion haben.
Oder jetzt kann ich auch gleich noch mal das Blog plagen. Das blog.chaosradio.cccde, da gibt es auch zu dieser Sendung einen Eintrag. Da kann man dann einfach mal so im Web kommentieren, wenn man nicht so ein E-Mail-Freund ist. Und wenn man nicht so gerne im Web kommentiert, dann kann man ja eine E-Mail schicken. Toll, was? Es gibt alles. Es gibt sogar ein Wiki bei uns.
Das ist da, wo man spampt kommt.
Ach so, meinst du, man Chaosradio Express so zu E-Mail machen? Sag doch mal. Bloß nicht. E-Mail ist vorbei. Das war früher. Fax.
Jetzt, wo meine Mama das langsam verstanden hat, sagst du, dass es vorbei ist.
Ja. So ist es doch immer mit den Technologien. Dann ist es nicht mehr cool. Dann darf man das sowieso nicht mehr benutzen.
Ich glaube, meine Mutter könnte das irgendwann mal hören. Du bist ja schon ein Mac-Fan und irgendwie gadgetwütig, aber ich glaube, meine Mutter überholt dich.
Echt?
Ja, krass.
Vielleicht kannst du mir mal ihre E-Mail-Adresse geben. Dann hast du ja noch ein paar gute Tipps für mich. So, jetzt sind wir schon eh bei dem Thema angekommen. Ich denke, die Technik haben wir jetzt eigentlich ausreichend abgedeckt. Nicht ganz?
Wieso?
Ach so, es gibt noch geheime Abkürzungen.
Die Sachen haben wir noch vergessen. Warum denn nicht BitTorrent so gut performt?
Ja, sag mal.
Und zwar, wenn jetzt, wir geben die Spuren zurück und es nicht hinkommt, sind wir wieder bei ABC. Du bist A, dein Opa und Oma sind B und deine Tanten und so sind C. So, du hast alles, 100 Prozent, hast alle Blöcke da. Opa und Opa sind schon so bei 50 Prozent und zwar irgendwelche Blöcke. Sie sind B und deine Tanten und so sind C. Die haben halt irgendwelche, aber die Hälfte der Blöcke. Deine Tanten, die haben noch gar nichts. Und damit das jetzt funktioniert, wäre es ja blöd für deine Tanten, wenn sie was runterladen, was deine Oma schon hat. Also das heißt, wenn C was runterlädt, was B noch nicht hat.
Was sie beide schon haben.
Also das heißt, als BitTorrent und Line versucht man immer was runterzuladen, was möglichst wenig Leute schon haben, damit man möglichst eine große Chance hat, das wieder zu verteilen. Weil wenn was keiner haben will, was ich habe, kann ich keinem was anbieten, dadurch geben sie mir wieder nichts und so weiter und so fort.
Prinzipiell Briefmarken tauschen.
Man will immer das haben, was am seltensten ist.
Man will immer haben, was am seltensten ist.
Das seltenste zuerst. Immer das seltenste.
Wenn jemand etwas haben will, dann hat er die Chance, dass jemand anderes etwas haben will.
Man sucht immer nach der blauen Mauritius. Und deswegen verteilen sich die Blöcke. Okay, verstehe. Weil ja auch jeder Kleinen sagen kann, was er haben will. Gib mal, was selten ist. Aber woher weiß er denn, was alle anderen haben?
Denk doch mal kurz nach, was wir dir von erzählt haben.
Es geht davon aus, dass alle Pirs miteinander verbunden sind. Also ich meine, wenn A, B und C da sind, A hat alles, und dann gibt es B und C, dann müssen ja B und C auch einander sehen, damit sie diese Optimierung machen können. Nicht automatisch. Wenn der Trecker B und C nicht miteinander verbindet, dann nicht.
Das ist natürlich nur mit denen, von denen du das sehen kannst. Da wir aber nicht nur A, B und C haben, sondern bis Z und dann noch reichlich mehr.
Und da nicht alle die gleiche Peerlist haben, sondern sozusagen verteilt, ist man mit allen mehr oder weniger verbunden.
Also überhaupt lebt alles von random. Die ganze Effizienz ist, möglichst wenig optimieren, sondern möglichst alles so zufällig wie möglich zu machen.
Den Gegenfall dokumentieren. Und zwar angenommen, du hast jetzt die 100%, Opa und Oma haben nichts und deine Tanten haben auch nichts. Opa und Oma laden jetzt Block Null runter und deine Tanten auch. Dann müsstest du schon wieder Block Null zweimal rausschieben und deine Tanten und deine Oma und Papas könnten untereinander nicht tauschen.
Weil sie haben ja schon das Gleiche.
Weil sie haben beide das Gleiche. Vielleicht ist der eine mal ein bisschen schneller, und dann würde es doch gehen, aber im Großen und Ganzen...
Wenn einer von den Piers verstirbt, dann möchtest du eigentlich schon, dass vielleicht da 50% von meinen 100% sind, dass ich nicht mehr da sein muss. Wenn ich mal nicht mehr bin, Junge, dann holst du dich von Onkel und Tante.
Bevor ich sterbe, verteile ich mein Erbe noch unter allen Inkeln.
Jetzt gibt es noch hier zwei Abkürzungen, zwei schöne TLAs.
Was ist ein TLA?
Ein TLA ist ein Three Letter Acronym. Eine dreibuchstabige Abkürzung. Und die erste heißt PEX. Was heißt denn das?
Damit kann der Client mit einem anderen Client schon Peer-Informationen austauschen. Das heißt, man braucht keinen Tracker mehr. Zum Beispiel, der Tracker fällt geradeaus, weil er wie immer überlastet ist. Und dann kriegt man wenigstens noch, falls man nur einen anderen Peer gerade sieht, kann man den fragen, gib du mir doch noch ein paar andere, nämlich die, die jagen sie. Und so können sich die Peers untereinander austauschen. Und selbst wenn der Tracker da ist, könnte man dadurch dafür sorgen, dass der Peer den Tracker nicht so oft fragen muss, weil er sich ja mit den anderen Peers selbst austauschen kann. Deshalb lastet eigentlich die Tracker.
Das ist auch wieder irgendetwas, was irgendein Client mal eingebaut hat?
Die steht im Wiki und damit haben es einfach mal Leute implementiert. Und wenn zwei Peers das implementiert haben, dann funktioniert das plötzlich. Ist nicht schlimm, wenn es nicht funktioniert. Es ist nur ein Paket, was auch noch mit über die Leitung drüber geht. Und wenn jemand dieses Paket nicht versteht...
Das heißt, das BitTorrent-Protokoll ist generell auch erweiterbar angelegt. Dass man so sagen kann, ich definiere jetzt mal einen neuen Pakettyp. Das heißt, es ist auch davon auszugehen, dass das BitTorrent-Protokoll in der Lage ist, sich weiteren Obstacles, die da so im Internet rumliegen, anpasst, indem einfach wieder irgendjemand eine Extension einbaut, die Peers schrittweise anfangen, das zu unterstützen und dann geht's.
Es mögen aber nicht alle Peer Exchange, weil es einige Tracker gibt, die wirklich nur Torrents verteilen, die sie auch selber anbieten auf ihrer Suchmaschine. Und sie wollen dann einfach nicht, dass Leute, die nicht bei ihnen vorbeigekommen sind, an dieser Wolke teilhaben können. Aus Gründen der Strafverfolgung, aus Gründen der, weiß nicht, Bezahlung. Bezahlung, oder das sind vielleicht sensitive Föhnendaten?
Aber das können sie ja gar nicht kontrollieren.
Und zwar ist das Pax-Bit, oder wie auch immer, das hat sich jetzt noch gar nicht richtig angehauen, muss irgendwie auch im Torrent-Fall eingetragen sein, ob man das möchte oder nicht. Dann ist nämlich sonst Pax disabled. Da habe ich gesagt, na ja, früher nach meinem BitTorrent-Klein eigentlich egal, was da drin steht. Und habe auch den Transmission-Programmierer gesagt, ich brauche das eigentlich nicht unterstützen, weil ich will immer Pax haben, weil das toll ist. Und dann sagten wir, ja, nee, das können wir aber nicht ignorieren, weil wenn wir das ignorieren, dann werden diese geschlossenen User-Groups, die es da gibt oder gab, so wie Oink zum Beispiel, die werden dann den BitTorrent-Klein bannen, weil er sich nicht an die Regeln hält.
Ah, verstehen. Das heißt, okay, weil die BitTorrent-Klein sich ja gegenüber dem Trecker auch zu erkennen geben als Hallo, ich bin sowieso.
Wenn die bei Oink-Torrents haben, wo die keine Pexen mögen und der Transmission-Klein sich zum Beispiel nicht dran hält, dann wird der Oink-Tracker sagen, nur Transmission-Kleins mögen wir nicht, weil die halten sich ja nicht an die Spiele.
Die verpetzen unsere Kunden und damit...
Das heißt, ich muss immer meinen BitTorrent-Klein irgendwie patchen. Hab ich aber auch noch nie gemacht, weil ich bin zu farbisch.
Man könnte natürlich auch in dem Torrent einfach den Trecker umtragen und sozusagen alleine anfangen, sobald man 100 Prozent hat. Der kennt ja wieder keiner. Du könntest ja 100 Prozent aus dieser geschlossenen Benutzergruppe runterladen und dann sozusagen davon...
Dann kannst du auch gleich einen neuen Torrent machen.
Wie man es dreht und wendet.
Ein Moment war noch, dass man Text selber einfach trotzdem einschalten. Das nützt aber nichts, weil höchstwahrscheinlich alle anderen BitTorrent-Kleins das nicht eingeschaltet haben und die deswegen nicht mit ihr...
Was war denn das zweite?
Das zweite TLA ist DHT, Distributed Hashtables. Erdgeist ist dein Einsatz.
Oh, hab nicht aufgepasst.
DHT, sag mal was total Kompliziertes, was nun Netz verstehen.
Distributed Hashtables sind Tabellen, die so verteilt sind, dass nicht alle, die die Informationen speichern, da sein müssen, um an diese Informationen zu kommen.
Super, das haben wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die Netz verstanden. Aber ich meine, was hat das jetzt mit BitTorrent zu tun?
Na, man kann Peers darüber finden, indem man diese Distributed Hashtables einfach sich selbst als Endpunktadresse in die Datenbank einträgt.
Worum geht's? Dass man jetzt keinen Trecker mehr braucht, oder was?
Das geht darum, dass man keinen Trecker mehr braucht.
Ah, okay, fangen wir doch erstmal mit der Erklärung an. Also DHT ist eine Technologie, mit der man Treckerless BitTorrent machen kann.
Genau. Indem man...
Wo findet der First Contact statt? Also zu wem connecte ich mich da mal einfach, wenn ich keinen Trecker habe?
Hätte ich nur mal nachgucken müssen.
Aber das ist im Prinzip die Idee, dass man eigentlich... Weil der Trecker ist ja nur dazu da, dass die Peer es sich finden. Und wenn die Peer es sich gefunden haben, dann sind die eigentlich happy. Okay, aber eigentlich jeder Peer kennt wieder irgendjemand, den der andere nicht kennt.
Ja, aber Pecs haben noch nicht alle.
Okay, aber die sind auch initial immer nötig.
Das heißt, dieses DRT spielt auch überhaupt keine Rolle. Das habe ich jetzt hier aufgeschrieben.
Das ist irgendwie ganz groß und die finden das ja auch ganz toll. Weil wie war es mit dem DRT? Genau, weil die meinten ja, die Trecker werden ja von... Gibt es ja noch die anderen Vorletter, die MPAA...
Das Gesetz.
Treckerindustrie, YMCA.
Recordingsindustrie.
Die Files finden bitte runter, nicht so toll. Und die machen immer mal so Trecker irgendwie...
Tod, versuchen platt.
Genau, die machen den Platt, schalten den aus oder sagen dem ISP, mach den mal aus, und dann machen wir dir keinen Stress. Passiert auch öfter mal, so wie in letzter Zeit, bei Demo und REAP. Und die bei Azuges oder bei anderen Clients, mal eine Denier, dafür wäre DHT und PECS ganz prima, weil dann brauchen wir ja keinen Trecker mehr.
Dann wird wieder ein Single Point of Fail herausgenommen.
Genau, aber der Nachfeld ist natürlich, dass es ja wiederum die Faker gibt. Die Faker müssen sich inzwischen nicht mehr zu einem Trecker connecten, um andere Peers zu kriegen, damit sie schlechte Daten versehen können. Sie hängen sich einfach irgendwo rein, holen sich mit PECS immer die Adressen und dann kann nicht mal der Trecker die rausfiltern. Was gibt der Trecker, die diese Faker schon kennen und die blocken diese in ihrem Business? Die kennen sich ja besser aus und blocken diese Adressen. Weil irgendwo müssen wir herkommen und dann erweitert das auch.
Mit anderen Worten ist es nicht gesagt, dass ein BitTorrent-Netz besser funktioniert, wenn es keine Trecker mehr gibt. Es kann auch durchaus sein, dass es mit den Treckern gar keine schlechte Idee war und dass es auch gehalten wird.
Dass man den Treckern deutlich keine schlechte Idee hat.
Jetzt haben wir eine schöne Überleitung gefunden, zum Bereich, den wir bisher noch komplett ausgespart haben, den man vielleicht sonst, wenn man so ein Thema diskutiert, als allererstes nehmen würde. Nämlich dieses Phänomen der populären BitTorrent-Zeits, die jetzt das Piratenkreuz oder auch andere Logos in der Fahne führen. Piratenkreuz, Piratenkopf.
Wir haben versucht, das zu anfangen.
Und zwar hieß es, ich glaube, das war das erste wirklich große, nämlich Supernova.
supernova.com Also wir reden jetzt von Websites, die... Ein Indexer. Genau, einen Indexer zu diesen Torrent-Dateien bieten. Also nicht die Tracker, sondern die Verzeichnisse.
Du gehst mit deinem Heimporn-Video-Torrent zu diesem Tracker und sagst, ich lade das jetzt mal hoch und alle, die danach irgendwie suchen und nach den Metadaten, die sich in diesem Fall befinden, die sollen diesen Torrent finden und die sollen mich dann am Ende auch über diesen Torrent wiederfinden.
Genau, ich annonziere sozusagen jetzt hier mein Zeug.
Genau und du nutzt deren Tracker, weil damals war es noch so, dass die nur Sachen angenommen haben, die deren eigenen Tracker angenommen haben.
Das heißt, Supra Nova war sowohl ein Web-Verzeichnis von Torrent-Dateien, was man durchsuchen konnte, als auch ein Tracker und man musste deren Tracker auch verwenden.
Das ist ein Torrent-File auch von denen runtergeladen. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt erstellst, lädst du es dort hoch und irgendwer anders findet das bei Supra Nova und kannst dann von Supra Nova auch wieder runterladen.
Von irgendwelchen verbotenen Dingen, die man nicht zahlen darf.
Es hat mich verboten, das ging einfach um unerwünschte Vervielfältigung. Das Schöne an dem Tracker nämlich ist, dass die bei dir mit einer großen Zahl vorbeikommen und du als Tracker-Betreiber nicht weißt, was diese große Zahl zu bedeuten hat. Aus dem Torrent wird die Check-Summe berechnet und der Pir kommt daher beim Tracker und sagt, ich habe da diesen Hash, diese Torrent-ID und ich möchte die traden. Und der Tracker selber, ja, ok, trage ich mir ein, weiß nicht, was es ist. Und wenn jemand nochmal kommt, dann...
Ok, also wir haben immer dieses Damokliss-Schwert der Verfolgung von Copyright-Sachen. Ich meine, sagen wir ehrlich, wir sehen das Thema auch etwas entspannter, weil wir eigentlich so frei nach Vorholland mit Gesetzen halt...
Vorausschauend umgehen.
Vorausschauend umgehen und wissen, dass es einfach eh alles nicht zu halten ist. Es ist einfach ein großer Dreck und es ist vor allem auch schlimm... Ja genau, diese Einstellung findet man ja auch bei der derzeitig populärsten Site, ganz deutlich wieder. Pirate Bay ist ja in aller Munde. piratebay.org ist das größte Verzeichnis von... Jetzt wird es interessant. Also was macht Pirate Bay? Supernova, haben wir gehört, macht alles. Die speichern die Torrents, sie bieten sie an im Web und sie haben den Tracker.
Ja und Pirate Bay macht auch das gleiche. Früher war Pirate Bay auch geschlossen und haben auch nur Sachen von ihrem eigenen Tracker angenommen. Also man musste mal Torrents erstellen, der mit einem Pirate Bay Tracker benutzt. Das ist inzwischen nicht mehr so. Und die haben 600.000 Torrents aktuell in der Verbreitung. Das heißt, man sucht innerhalb von 600.000 Torrents. Und die haben 4-5-6 Millionen User, die da aktiv unterladen.
Aktiv, nicht nur die irgendwie.
Denn nicht irgendwann machen wir das so wie jetzt.
4 Millionen Leute, die gleichzeitig irgendwie gerade was damit tun.
In der letzten Dreiviertelstunde vorbeigekommen sind.
Aber Pirate Bay ist, weil es schon so lange professionell gemacht wird und sich auch sehr wiederbrachstisch irgendwie Anwälte von der NPA und RIA und was weiß ich nicht.
Schredder.
Genau, die sind da knallhart und vor allem die, also einerseits nutzen sie die liberale Gesetzgebung in Schweden, um sich ein bisschen den Rücken freizuhalten. Auf der anderen Seite sind sie aber auch...
Die sind in den Niederlanden. Die sind gerade nach den Niederlanden umgezogen.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Die Webseite steht in Schweden. Und das ist aus dem einfachen Grund, weil ja auch immer noch die Frage besteht, ist es denn illegal, diese Torrent-Index-Seiten zu betreiben? Weil in den Torrents stehen ja keinerlei, sind keinerlei Daten, die irgendwie urheberrechtlich geschützt sind. Da sind Hashes drinne von Daten. Die Daten selber liegen gar nicht auf der Webseite. Also in diesen Index-Seiten befindet sich keinerlei Inhalt, der irgendjemandem gehört. Da liegen halt Torrent-Files rum, die man runterlassen kann.
Aber die Argumentation ist natürlich dann so...
Es ist Beihilfe.
Genau, so ist das eine Beihilfe zur Straftat.
In Schweden gibt es halt diese Beihilfe nicht. Deswegen ist Pirate Bay in Schweden relativ sicher, weil sozusagen ist da kein Straftatbestand der Beihilfe in dem Sinne gibt.
Die Namen sind jetzt schon ein paar Jahre, und weil die so stabil sind von ihren Adressen, sind Pirate Bay auf, haben sie natürlich auch eine große Userzahl.
Und sie haben natürlich den entsprechenden Medienrummel immer mit dem Raid, den sie da hatten. Also sind halt einmal mit der Polizei eingeritten und haben die komplette Pirate Bay-Ausrüstung eingepackt und haben sie zur Staatsanwaltschaft plus die Nachbarrechner und alles, was in dem Rechenzentrum stand, und haben halt einmal komplett Pirate Bay runtergefahren, wo auf den Pirate Bay halt auf einen anderen ISP ausgewichen ist und gleich wieder aufgemacht hat. Und die Rechner stehen, glaube ich, immer noch mit dem Staatsanwalt und sie erbeten sich immer noch Zeit darüber, weiterhin diese Rechner zu durchsuchen, um irgendwelche Daten zu finden. Aber es ist völlig egal, was sie da jetzt suchen. Es gibt da einfach irgendwie keine Daten, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise sinnvoll zu durchforsten sind.
Ja, die Story kann man auch nochmal bei Chaosradio nachhören. Ich habe ja mit dem Beta von Pirate Bay damals ein Interview gemacht, 2006, als das passiert ist. Chaosradio Express International 999. Ein Channel, auf dem wenig passiert, aber das liegt daran, dass ich da immer nur dann was produziere, wenn sich halt auch mal ein internationaler Gast wieder zum interessanten Thema vor meiner Nase einfindet. So, trotzdem, also, worauf ich dann hinaus wollte, ist, abgesehen davon, dass sie da, wie man es auch immer nennen mag, also die Gesetzeslage nutzen. Oder sagen wir einfach, was heißt sie nutzen? Das ist einfach nur mal die Gesetzeslage in Schweden. Sie tun einfach das, was nicht verboten ist. Und darüber hinaus ist es aber auch so, dass sie einfach ganz klar die Meinung vertreten, dass das, was sie da tun, einfach auch mal zulässig ist. Weil die Realität ist, es wird kopiert. Und es wird auch immer kopiert werden, egal...
Nicht nur zusätzlich, sondern auch sozusagen nützlich für die Gesellschaft. Das ist auch eine ihrer Punkte, dass sie sagen, es gehört einfach zur Gesellschaft dazu, dass kopiert wird.
Und es muss getan werden. Und man muss geradezu etwas dafür tun, um es zu unterstützen.
Das ist das Material, was sie sozusagen geschaffen haben.
Das ist ja eh alles. Das ist eh alles.
Warum müssen wir eigentlich noch mal Leute dafür bezahlen, unseren eigenen Kram zu hören? Das ist so ein bisschen so dieses Mindset, was dahinter steht.
Aber da kann man jetzt eine längliche Diskussion drüber führen. Es ist ja auch so, dass die meisten der Meinung sind, dass man nur auf den Schultern von Giganten das erreichen kann, was man gerade erreicht, indem man sich an der Gesellschaft schon bedient hat und jetzt so unglaublich viel Geld abzugreifen für die Werke, die da verteilt werden, nicht gerechtfertigt ist. Aber das ist eine längliche philosophische Diskussion.
Ja, die wir jetzt nicht leicht in voller epischer Breite hier führen wollen. Genau. Aber es ist schön, dass wir mal darüber gesprochen haben, weil ich denke, das ist auch so ein bisschen wichtig. Insbesondere, wenn wir jetzt mal so nochmal die Liste vervollständigen von populären Sites, bevor wir dann auch noch zu eurem Projekt kommen, was ja so ein bisschen der Grund ist, warum ich euch in dieser Runde jetzt auch so zusammengebracht habe. Was auch noch sehr bekannt ist, ist Mininova. Die haben aber einen anderen Ansatz, oder?
Die sind sozusagen nur so eine Art Meta-Suchmaschine, die tracken eigentlich Pirate Bay zum Beispiel und andere und packen das in eine große Datenbank und machen das dann suchbar. Und damit natürlich auch dort Leute, die ein Torrent erstellen wollen, so wie du für den Mobi, geben die natürlich dann auch da Track-Adressen, an die man dann benutzen kann.
Da kommen wir später dazu.
Wir geben da die Track-Adressen an, wo sie wissen, die sind halt offen, dass man die benutzen kann. Und Pirate Bay fragt ja auch ab, sodass man ein bisschen Statistiken bekommt, sodass da zum Beispiel jetzt gerade tausend Zieder sind und irgendwie 2000 Download. Damit man so ein bisschen sieht, ist der Torrent dann noch aktiv oder nicht, weil es ist ja auch eine wichtige Sache. Wo man nur 0,0 steht und da ist gerade gar keiner da, warum man gar nicht versuchen runterzuladen, da ist ja keiner. Und das machen diese Meter, seit es so wenig noch mal einer ist.
Und davon gibt es ja wirklich viele.
Davon gibt es ja auch violente viele und ich kenne die auch überhaupt gar nicht alle, weil die kann man gar nicht alle kennen. Und brauchen wir noch alle gar nicht kennen, weil das sowieso alle, die graben sich alle gegenseitig macht. Es ist genauso, ob du Google fragst oder Alter, bist du da, ok, inzwischen ist das so ein Unterschied. Aber es gab eine Zeit, mal eine Weile lang war es mal kein Unterschied, weil die graben alle das gleiche ab und so ist es bei diesen toppen Zeitz auch. Also hier gibt es zum Beispiel noch Isohunt. Und das ist auch so eine Metersuche. Und alles, was bei Pirate Bays ist, ist auch immer bei Isohunt. Vielleicht, wenn es bei Pirate Bays gerade frisch ist, dann ist es bei Isohunt noch nicht, aber sonst kannst du eigentlich auch nur bei Isohunt suchen, weil die haben alles. Das ist auch eine der größten Metersuche-Zeits.
Meter, Meter, Meter, Meter. Das zahlt sich eigentlich auch aus, dass BitTorrent erst mal auf das Suchen selber verzichtet hat. BitTorrent als Protokoll, meine ich jetzt. Und die können...
Das ist auch eine ganz andere Baustelle, was die Optimierung angeht.
Und das sind aber auch die, die dann am Ende sozusagen eigentlich die fette Kohle verdienen, nehme ich zumindest mal an. Weil die Kleinschreiber, ich glaube, die verdienen nichts oder die machen es ja mehr zum Spaß. Also der Transmission-Client auf dem Weg, die verdienen nichts, die Jungs, das ist ja Pre-Ware oder Ocosource. Und die Azurios, die Wonswile kauft, aber die verbreiten den natürlich trotzdem umsonst. Die wollen jetzt unseren Portal hochziehen mit irgendwie Video oder so. Aber im Grunde genommen hat seine Firma jetzt, die wollen es ja auch machen. Mit ihrem...
Also richtig reich geworden ist er damit noch nicht, oder?
Nee, es gibt eine Menge Venture-Capitalisten drin, wahrscheinlich Prozente von seinem Hauptanteil abgegeben, aber ob er da wirklich Geld verdient, ist eine tolle Geschichte. Aber diese Metasearch-Maschinen da, die können natürlich so viel Werbung schreiben, weil die auch so viel Hits haben. Weil die natürlich die ganzen Leute, die BitTorrent runterladen den ganzen Tag, müssen die Torrent-Files ja auch irgendwo her haben. Und die klicken halt da drauf und dann ist halt irgendwie... Und der Typ von Isohand, das konnte man... Also dieses Jahr oder letztes Jahr hatte er auch... Er wurde in Amerika irgendwie weggeklagt oder seinem ISP wurde Druck gemacht, sodass er schnell mal nach Kanada auslagern musste. Und er hatte irgendwie innerhalb von zwei Tagen 50.000 Dollar Paypal-Spenden. Ich glaube, das war weniger, er hat glaube ich 50.000 Dollar neue Hardware gekauft. Egal, da fießen auf jeden Fall große Summen, wenn ich so eine Zahlung höre. Und da sieht man, dass da schon ein bisschen Geld über den Tisch geht. Also so arm kann er nicht sein, wenn er sich leisten kann, auf Risiko irgendwie für 50.000 Dollar neue Hardware zu kaufen.
Das haben aber die Leute auch eine Menge davon haben.
Deswegen sind die vier Buchstaben mit Bekürzung auch meistens hinter diesen Indexseiten hinterher, weil die halt wirklich damit auch noch Geld verdienen.
Das ist auch die erste Anlaufstelle für jemanden, der sich dann nicht einer fragt, hier hast du folgende Filme, sag ich jetzt mal so. Dann sagst du denen hier ISO, dann gucken die da und dann gibt's ihn dann wahrscheinlich. Also das wissen die MPRA und AIR auch und dann versuchen sie halt...
Es ist schon ganz interessant zu sehen, dass sie jetzt eigentlich versuchen, die Sites aufzubohren oder runterzubringen, die tatsächlich schon ein neues Geschäftsmodell gefunden haben, auf Basis moderner Distributionstechnik.
Das, was sie eigentlich selber machen müssten.
Das, was sie eigentlich selber machen müssten. Da hauen sie einfach drauf ein, anstatt zu sehen so, oh Scheiße, da ist ja richtig viel Geld zu verdienen, warum machen wir denn das eigentlich nicht?
Aber da hat ja letztens auch einer von diesen Copyright-Leuten auch irgendwie gesagt, dass sie technisch davon keine Ahnung haben und dass jeder Troll, der da vorbeikommt und sagt, ich hab davon Ahnung, dem glauben sie das, weil sie wissen nicht, was sie tun. Es ist einfach nicht ihr Business. Internet ist nicht ihr Business.
Das ist wirklich ein Trauerspiel mit den Jungs. Sie lassen sich auch noch alles komplett aus der Hand nehmen. Das Schlimme ist nur, dass sie dann halt irgendwie versuchen, das über die Politik dann wieder alles zu machen. Tralala, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, so haben wir jetzt schön, jetzt kommen sie wieder gleich alle angestellt.
Die haben da ähnlich viel Ahnung in der Politik wie die in der Wirtschaft.
Ja, ja, das ist noch schlimmer.
Noch weniger Ahnung.
Die Zahl oder der Umsatz der Spielehersteller ist, glaube ich, inzwischen größer als der Umsatz der Musik.
Es gab da mal so eine Zahl, ja.
Da wurde dann natürlich genauso kopiert. Die sind hinter diesen Torn-Sides nicht so stark, ja?
Nein, da gibt es aber auch welche, die hinterher sind. Es gibt diesen Pinball-Fall und so.
Ja gut, aber im Gaming-Bereich gibt es natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Kopierschutzmechanismen, die tatsächlich auch greifen. Also so eine modifizierte Wii oder so habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Es funktioniert trotzdem, weil man lebt eigentlich immer nur von den Hardcore-Fans.
Im Endeffekt ist das richtige Geld, die Leute holen die Leute eh nicht aus der Software, die sie verkaufen, sondern aus eigentlichen Gebühren. Das sieht man auch an World of Warcraft. Dann kriegst du halt das Spiel für einen Apel und ein Ei und noch irgendwie ein Monatspiel. Dann zahlst du halt jeden Monat und damit verdient man das richtige Geld. Nicht mit einer DVD, die man über den Ladentisch schiebt. Damit verdient man irgendwie kein Geld. Sollte man nicht.
Sollte man nicht. Böse, böse, böse, böse, böse. Ja, so, jetzt haben wir es schon tausendmal angedeutet. Also in unserer Vorbesprechung, ich weiß nicht, wer es gesagt hat, hast du es gesagt, Cryx, irgendwie BitTorrent reizt die USA aus.
Nein, das war Erdgeist.
Erdgeist hat es gesagt. Okay, Erdgeist. Also diese Sites, wir haben ja schon extreme Zahlen gehört. Vier Millionen User gleichzeitig, 600.000 Torrents, das sind ja einfach enorme Mengen. Und was ich weiß, ist, dass irgendwie bei Pirate Bay schon immer irgendwie die Maschinen geglüht haben. Was ist denn da so die Lastproblematik in der Stelle? Wo schmilzt denn die Elektronik, wenn BitTorrent betrieben wird im Internet?
Die Elektronik schmilzt genau an der Stelle, die halt auch die zentralen Punkte sind, bei denen die Tiers vorbei müssen. Und das sind die Tracker. Halt beim Wegspeichern der Files machen sie schon noch viel falsch und können dann halt auch die Festplatte zum Glühen bringen. Aber ansonsten haben die wenig zu tun. Genau, aber genau beim Finden der anderen Tiers, da bedienen sie sich der Hilfe der Tracker. Und dieser Tracker muss halt, wie ich vorhin schon angedeutet, HTTP sprechen mit vielen Tiers gleichzeitig. Die da einfach vorbeikommen. Einige halten sich an die Zeit, die man ihnen sagt, andere halten sich nicht daran. Die kommen da vorbei und wollen Bescheid sagen, dass sie diesen Torrent haben und tauschen möchten. Und sie möchten auch alle Adressen abhaben. Und das machen auf dem Trecker, den wir aufgesetzt haben, so was wie 3000 Tiers pro Sekunde. Das machen bei Pirate Bay 17000 Tiers pro Sekunde. Und das sind so die Größenordnungen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man sich das vorstellen kann. Diese 17000 Verbindungen pro Sekunde sind halt immer neuen Pakete, die da hin und her gehen. Das kann man dann wieder mal ausrechnen. Und darauf muss man dann halt dieses komplexe Protokoll HTTPS sprechen.
Das heißt, das ist eine Riesenlast für den Rechner in Datenmengen, vor allem in der Unterscheidung von verschiedenen Verbindungen. Da müssen die Betriebssysteme interne Ressourcen bereitstellen.
Man muss sich das so vorstellen, das ist sozusagen Spiegel Online und da ist ein Content-Management-System und das ist eine Datenbank, die die Artikel rausholt. Und da kommen Leute vorbei und die klicken da nicht 150 Leute gleichzeitig auf den Reload-Button, sondern halt 3500 gleichzeitig, irgendwie jede Sekunde.
Also meinst du, ein Trecker ist deutlich mehr der Beschuss als Spiegel Online?
Dauerhaft.
Oha, das heißt, zwischendurch flammt's richtig.
Gut, wir müssen sagen, dass irgendwie gerade die 3000 auch die Traffic-Grenze sind. Ansonsten, so ein einzelner Rechner bei Pirate Bay macht da irgendwie auch mal 5000, 6000.
3000 ist jetzt nur so eine Zahl, das geht auch locker irgendwie höher.
Also wenn irgendwie gerade eine neue Serie rausgekommen ist und die halt irgendwie alle gerade die neue, weiß nicht, Gilmore Girls, kommt es noch? Ich mache ja sowas halt nicht. Ja. Wenn die halt sich die neue Heroes Folge, wenn die gerade rausgekommen ist, dann hat man so Stoßzeiten, Stoßzeiten, wo dann halt auch wie 10.000 auf einem einzigen Rechner einschlagen und Bescheid wissen wollen, wer denn noch auf diesem Tor runter verteilt.
Da war bisher halt immer ein Problem, weil die meiste Tracker-Software war halt entweder damals an den Blankone natürlich erstmal von Hand gestiegen, entpüht und die war natürlich nicht so schnell. Später kamen dann die Erweiterungen, wo sie irgendwelche Mini-Web-Server genommen haben und die umgekodet wurden. Oder halt sogar ein PHP.
Mit MySQL-Backend.
Mit MySQL-Backend, genau. Und die haben natürlich auch gar nicht performt. Also das funktioniert alles prima und die wurden bestimmt auch schnell entwickelt. Und war erstmal alles ganz toll. Aber die waren halt nie vorgesehen für mehr als 200-300 Request pro Sekunde. Pirate Bay aber zum Beispiel, die brauchen einfach mal mehr. Deswegen hatten die da einen, der nennt sich Anakata. Und der hat irgendwie einen Web-Server namens Hypercube angepasst. War aber schon erstmal ganz schnell und hat schon irgendwie so ein paar tausend geschafft pro Sekunde. Aber die Rechner von Pirate Bay, die waren aber auch am Ende.
Am Anschlag.
Also wir haben mal geguckt bei denen und die waren mit ihrem Prozess immer bei 100% und da ging nichts mehr. Also ich könnte mir auch schon gut vorstellen, dass eine Menge Request nicht schnell genug beantwortet haben und die deswegen fallen gelassen wurden. Also es hätte schicker sein können.
Also das Ding ist, dass allein durch das Treckerprotokoll in HTTP Programmierer schon ziemlich leicht in Versuchung geraten, einfach eine bestehende HTTP-Protokollimplementation in Form eines Web-Servers zu benutzen. Und darauf einfach nur ein CGI oder was Ihnen da gerade in die Hände fällt in der Programmiersprache, die Sie beherrschen zu programmieren. Und damit hast du schon das erste Bottleneck, das dann irgendwie nicht mehr integriert ist, dass der Web-Server sich dann darum kümmern muss, ein Plugin an Start zu bekommen und mit dem über nicht integrierte Protokolle starten zu können.
Lüften wir doch mal erst den Schleier. Ihr habt ein Projekt gestartet unter dem Namen OpenTracker. OpenTracker ist ein BitTorrent-Tracker. Und das ist neu geschrieben von Grund auf. Geschrieben in C und der ist schnell.
Das ist so der Schnellste.
Der Schnellste.
Können wir, glaube ich, ohne uns zu bewerfen, sagen, der Schnellste.
Wie viel schneller als der Rest ist es?
Es ist schwer zu sagen, weil der alte Tracker, der bei Pirate Bay lief, immer oben ans Limit geschlagen ist. Damit kann man nicht sagen, wie viele es wirklich gewesen wären. Aber ansonsten, das Fünffache, während er früher auf 100% lief und nicht alle Clients abbekommen hat, kriegen wir jetzt alle Clients hin und laufen bei rund 20%.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Information, die wir jetzt hier gerade vermitteln, ist, dass Pirate Bay, die größte Bitschlampe im Internet, jetzt vor kurzem wann? Vor zwei Wochen?
Ja, also wir testen es schon eine Weile und auf euer System umgeschaltet ist. Noch nicht komplett.
Noch nicht komplett, aber weitgehend. Und sie haben es auch vor. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt diese Software entdeckt, vor einigen Wochen getestet, für gut befunden.
Da kam halt jemand vorbei, der in Berlin durch Zufall mit den Jungs von Pirate Bay unterwegs war. Der war auf einer Veranstaltung. Tom Pritlove, oder?
Ja, ich bin jetzt wieder schuld. Ja, war eine ganz interessante Veranstaltung. Kann man ja auch gleich nochmal erwähnen. Das war vor drei Wochen. Genau, All of the 21st Century. Von dem... Wie heißt das auch gleich? Sebastian, der auch Text dort kommt, Sebastian Lüttgart. Er hat das organisiert. War eine sehr interessante Veranstaltung, wo halt diverse Leute aus dieser ganzen BitTorrent und sonstigen P2P-Community zusammen waren. Hier Mininova war da, Leute von Oint war da. Genau, also das war schon sehr interessant.
Da gab es halt die Premiere von Steels Film 2.
Genau, der demnächst kommt, der irgendwie seit Wochen angekündigt ist, dass er im November kommt. Ich warte.
Die Jungs sind so ein bisschen überlässig.
Einen Tag haben wir noch. Also morgen muss er eigentlich rauskommen.
Vielleicht ist deren Webserver nicht schnell genug.
Ja, also treue Chaosradio-Abonnenten haben natürlich ChaosTV abonniert. Da wird er dann auch sofort rausfallen, sowie auch Teil 1. Ich muss auch sagen, dieser Teil 2 ist sehr viel besser als Teil 1. Da haben sie richtig viel Arbeit reingesteckt. Ziemlich cooler Film. Ich bin gespannt. Untertitel ist The Dissolving Fortress, wie auch immer. Da an dem Wochenende ist die Verbindung hergestellt worden zum Open-Tracker-Projekt und seitdem läuft Pirate Bay mit Open-Tracker.
Wir haben uns kurz unsere Features erzählt und dass wir schnell sind und sauber in C-Code und kein anderes Giraffe, was nicht benötigt wird, hat er sich irgendwie angehört und schon ein paar Tage später haben wir schon gemerkt, dass er unsere Software einsetzt. Dann hat es noch ein paar Tage länger gedauert und dann haben sie es auch noch auf ein paar Mehrtrackern gemacht und jetzt fehlt nur noch der größte von ihnen, den sie umschalten wollen. Sie brauchen dann noch ein paar Features, haben sie auch bekommen und eigentlich könnten sie jetzt schon umschalten.
Wahrscheinlich sind sie mit dem Film beschäftigt.
Na gut, Pirate Bay, das ist ja noch mal separat.
Man meint, er ist irgendwie im Umzug oder so, aber es hat gerade nicht so Zeit. Also wir haben ihn gerade geraucht.
Wir haben von Ihnen...
Gratuliere. Das heißt, okay, könnt ihr vielleicht noch ein bisschen was zu der Tracker-Software sagen? Ich meine, sie macht eigentlich was sehr Einfaches. Sie vermittelt mit Peer-Clients.
Ich meine, wenn man das Problem auf allerhöchster Ebene von oben drauf guckt, dann heißt das einfach, da kommt jemand vorbei, der hat irgendwie einen Merkmal, und zwar vier Byte für seine IP-Adresse, zwei Byte für den Port von dem er kommt und bringt einem 20 Byte vorbei, die diese Torrent-ID sind, der Hash, und er will genau dieselben Informationen zu diesen 20 Byte, also sprich IP und den Port von allen anderen. Das ist das, was der Tracker zu lösen hat, das Problem. Da kommt natürlich noch dahin, dass er das aus dem HTTP, aus der URL herausfriemeln muss und auf der anderen Seite noch in einem lustigen Format, was sich Bremkoden ausgedacht hat, so heißt B encoded, da muss das wieder reinschreiben. Kann man aber ziemlich einfach machen. Wenn man das Problem so weit verstanden hat, dann kann man sich hinsetzen und das mal so in C implementieren, wie es gedacht ist. Also ich sehe halt immer, dass man in C programmieren soll, was man in C leicht programmieren kann, kann es von meinem Bier haben. Und halt irgendwie, für schnelles Prototyping eignet sich Python deutlich besser. Und wenn das mal abgehangen ist, dann kann man es halt noch mal richtig machen in einer Programmiersprache, die schnell ist.
Also zum Entwickeln war das eine coole Sache, aber für Performance taugt es einfach mal nicht, so wie C. Genau. Zumindest, wenn man C ordentlich programmiert.
Aber ich stand da halt genauso wie die Musikmacher und Filmer auch wieder auf den Schultern von Giganten. Der Fefe hatte vorher eine Bibliotheke geschrieben, die einem ziemlich elegant und ziemlich schnell erlaubt, viele Verbindungen auf einem eigenen Rechner zu verwalten, die Systemressourcen optimal auszunutzen. Und hatte da auch schon ein Beispiel, eine DPS Server zu geschrieben. Und den habe ich genommen, habe 90% weggeworfen und den Rest neu gemacht. Und ja, habe dann halt den...
Und dann lief das. Wie lange hast du daran rumgehackt?
Ich hack bis heute rum, um noch Features reinzumachen. Aber bis es halt so grob stabil lief, waren das, glaube ich, sechs Wochen, sieben Wochen.
Was für Features braucht man denn da? Ich meine, wenn das Ding so wenig macht, was muss denn der Tracker leisten? Also dieses Feature, was wir vorhin erwähnt haben, liefert auch mal IP-Adressen aus, die es nicht gibt. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch da drin.
Dass der Tracker lief, das ging eigentlich relativ schnell, aber da hat man halt diesen Tool, was läuft und man kann nicht mehr reingucken. Und was wir brauchten halt, damit wir tausende von Richtwesten die Sekunde abfeuern können, ist, dass wir auch mal gucken können, von welchen Adressen kommen die, wo geht da was schief, aus welchen Gründen geht da was schief, wie viel kommt denn überhaupt, damit wir Statistiken erstellen können, also so grafisch, dass da den Tast über das Meer los, als abends oder andersrum kommt, oder aus welcher Zeit so viele Leute ankommen. Also, dass wir ein bisschen mehr mitkriegen. Und das hören wir halt nach.
Man kommt da an, ziemlich interessante Debugging-Probleme. Wenn nämlich da 2000 Leute pro Sekunde einschlagen, dann kann man nicht mal schnell Printf einbauen, um sich da anzugucken, was da grad passiert. Dann ist der Großteil des Traffics auf dem Server deine Debug-Verbindung. Und man kann auch nicht mal schnell versuchen, nachzuvollziehen, was da eigentlich grad auf dem Rechner passiert, weil halt so viel Feuer auf einen Server hinzubekommen, da braucht's schon echt eine verteilte Infrastruktur, das kriegst du auf einem Server nicht mehr hin.
Du kannst es also zu Hause auf deinem Laptop nicht vernünftig nachbilden. Du kannst da keine virtuelle Umgebung basteln, wenn du das einfach mal nachstellst.
Braucht ihr ja schon mal so einen richtigen Trecker, der auch unter Feuer steht.
Ja, ich hab dann also programmiert mit so 100.000 von Betatestern gleichzeitig.
Das war ein Witz, weil er das immer programmiert und ich das immer austeste. Und dann lief er dann irgendwann mal nicht und der Erdgeist so sagt, ja, machen wir dann schon irgendwann nicht so, aber dann sind da so ein paar hunderttausend, die gerade nicht hinterlassen. Wie, was, 100.000 sind's schon? Das ist schon 100.000, dieser Wahnsinn.
Das heißt, ihr hattet da einfach einen Tracker, der irgendwie in diesen Listen bei diesen ganzen Hauptsites einfach mit drin kam.
Denis hat früher mal einfach aus Spaß in seiner Küche auf seinem Router, weil er dachte halt, dieses Protokoll ist zwar cool, aber da braucht es viele Tracker dazu, dass es halt nicht so leicht angegriffen werden kann.
Das heißt, wenn du was zu deinem Opa schicken wolltest, dann musstest du das bei Pirate Bay oder bei Supernova irgendwie hochladen, damit die das da runterladen können. Du konntest aber nicht einen freien Trecker, gab es irgendwie noch. Also gab es bestimmt welche, aber für mich gab es erst mal keine. Da dachte ich, das ist irgendwie blöde. Wenn ich mit meinen Kumpels irgendwie Sachen austauschen will, dann will ich das nicht da hochladen. Ich will den Torrent direkt geben und dann meinen Trecker benutzen. Zudem ist man ja als Nerd auch immer so ein bisschen ein service Mensch.
Genau, und ich will auch noch mal hinzufügen, für die Leute, die jetzt so zuhören, und sich denken so, oh Gott, hier geht es ja echt nur um Musiktraining oder so. Ich meine, es gibt auch diesen Bedarf. Man muss halt auch manchmal einfach eine DVD übertragen. Genau, dicke Videos gerade, genau, das ist auch so ein gutes Thema.
Und so ein Problem, den zu verteilen, und BitTorrent eignet sich wunderbar dafür.
Das performt einfach. Podcasting ist eigentlich auch so ein Video. Also es gibt ja auch tatsächlich Podcast-Clients, die BitTorrent unterstützen. Schon lange übrigens, allerdings die großen populären, sprich iTunes, machen das nicht. Warum, da kann man lange drüber...
Na ja, es gibt da so das Problem, dass man Torrents halt nicht in beliebige Reihenfolge reinbekommt, so dass man halt immer erst komplett runtergeladen haben muss, bis man sich das anhören kann.
Ja gut, aber das ist bei Podcasting nicht so das Problem.
Bei Podcasting und BitTorrent, das passt wunderbar zusammen. Also die einzige Einschränkung, die ich sehe, ist, und das mag auch eine Motivation sein, warum Apple das nicht gemacht hat, auf Server-Seite, du hast dann einfach keine amtlichen Statistiken mehr. Du weißt nicht, wie viele Leute deine Scheiße geholt haben und wer es geholt hat.
Ja, aber dann muss jeder einen Tracker betreiben.
Wenn sie fertig sind mit dem Download, das kriegt der Tracker zum Beispiel mit und könnte sich das merken.
Ja, okay, gut, das ist ein interessanter Ansatz, dass man das vielleicht darüber auch wiederholt. Aber wie auch immer, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich meine, Apple sitzt natürlich auch bei Akamai mit den Aktien und die lösen das Problem einfach anders.
Mit der Keule.
Ja, mit der Keule. Die haben ja auch die Infrastruktur, mit der das dann auch wunderbar geht. Von daher haben die das auch nicht nötig. Und für unsere Distributionsprobleme sind sie ja wahrscheinlich nicht zuständig, fast weiß ich. Andererseits ist BitTorrent-Protokoll am Anfang oder in den ersten Jahren auch immer ein Moving Target gewesen. Also das ist halt nicht gerade jetzt ein IEEE-Standard.
Von den Kompasspekten muss ich erst noch rumsprechen, dass Blizzard da mit den Leuten am Workoff so weit vorne war.
Genau, also ich fände das schon interessant und das könnte für viele Podcaster, die auch populär sind, durchaus mal ein Traffic-Problem lösen. Aber da ist leider die Verbindung noch nicht so weit. Aber wie auch immer, wir waren jetzt bei diesen Open Trackern, dass man sowas mal gebrauchen kann.
Ich hatte einen, der wurde unter Kumpels eingesetzt und dann plötzlich die Nutzerrate von Leuten, die ich nicht kannte. Ich habe nur gesehen, da sind Torrents in meinem Trecker, von denen ich nicht wusste, was die machen. Ich habe nur die ID gesehen und sonst nichts. Und dachte mir, benutzen halt Leute, lässt sie halt an, lässt sie an und lässt sie an. Und dann irgendwann wurden es 20-30 Torrents mit so ein paar Klicks. Das sind ja dann nicht ganz so viele. Und weiß nicht, nach ein paar Monaten waren es dann schon ganz schön viele. Und irgendwann hat meine Leitung zu Hause nicht ausgereicht und da musste ich mal umziehen. Und ich habe aber immer noch die ganze Zeit den Pythonsauce eingesetzt, also den Pythontracker. Der skaliert halt, ich glaube, bis 80 oder so.
60 haben wir am Ende.
Und es ist ja eigentlich immer nichts, wenn man jetzt überlegt, dass wir bei Pirate Bay schon was von ein paar tausend oder fünftausend erzählt haben. Jedenfalls meint der Erdgeist dann, das ist noch HTTP, ich fange da mal an. Dann habe ich meinen Pythontracker weiter laufen lassen. Dann kam er irgendwann und meinte, jetzt hier teste ich mal. Dann haben wir mal einen Test gemacht, der lief dann am Anfang erst mal mit 0% Load. Man konnte gar nicht sehen, das ist immer etwas tief. Der Python war schon wie bei 80% Load. Und einer war immer noch bei 0%, man dachte, der Python funktioniert nicht, aber er funktioniert ja genauso.
Schnell programmieren ist schon was wert. Also sowohl schnell fertig werden, als auch schnell das Software machen.
Oder am besten schnell, schnell das Software machen.
Wo gibt es die Software?
Die gibt es im Google Open Tracker.
Gibt es keine URL?
Doch, die ist nur länglich. Arts, Kunst, Künste.
Ach so, Arts.
Software.
Slash Open Tracker.
Das heißt, das läuft bei dir unter Kunst. Das ist ja schön, natürlich. Und da ist dann auch ein Tracker. Ein Open und Free BitTorrent-Tracker. Also wer jetzt irgendwie hier zuhört und der Meinung ist, er bräuchte ja auch mal einen Performanten-Tracker. Und das braucht man ja nicht nur, wenn man 17.000 Verbindungen gleichzeitig hat, sondern das heißt ja auch, man hat eine Software, mit der man sehr langsame Hardware auch zu einem Tracker umwandeln kann. Also man könnte das auch auf einem Router oder so was. Genau, auf seinem DSL-Router könnte man jetzt Open Tracker installieren. Der ist wahrscheinlich auch recht klein, wie ich dich kenne. 40 Kilobyte ist die Software groß. Das ist die ausführbare Binary. Und dann läuft das irgendwie auch prima auf so einem Linux DSL-Router oder so. Auf deinem Open Open ist das nicht.
Das wollte man zum Kongress mal ausprobieren. Das Problem beim DSL-Router ist natürlich, dass die Adresse sich bewegt. Dass du dann vielleicht noch das mit dünnen DNS verbinden müsstest. Die haben aber dann Probleme damit.
Sag mal.
Das ist bekannt geworden durch Paul Hellingkamp. Das ist ein Freebase-Deprogrammierer, der meinte, dieses GPL-Zeugs ist doch einfach lächerlich. Ich will, dass mein Name drüber steht. Und wenn irgendjemand die Software nützlich findet, dann soll er mir ein Bier ausgeben. Und ich finde die Lizenz sehr sympathisch. Und habe alle meine Open-Source-Software unter dieser Lizenz rausgebracht.
Und man kriegt immer mal ein Bier irgendwo spendet.
Also kommt alle auf den 24. Chaos-Communication-Kongress. Das sollte man eh noch mal erwähnen.
Wenn ihr irgendetwas bei Pirate Bay runtergeladen habt, dann müsst ihr mit dem Bier vorbeikommen.
Jeder von euch, der schon mal was bei Pirate Bay, das dürfte jetzt eine sehr kleine Zahl von Leuten sein.
Wir machen einfach einen Stand unten bei der Cafeteria. Wir machen einen Stand, Open Trecker hier.
Du musst ja zu nichts kommen, außer saufen.
Die Bier, die ich heute mitgebracht habe, die waren natürlich für Denis und Cryx, die mich bei dem Projekt so wundervoll unterstützt haben und zuweilen selber Software geschrieben haben und die jetzt auch dank der Bierwehr-Lizenz ihr Bier redlich verdient haben.
Wir haben auch mal schöne Arbeitstörungen gemacht. Der Erdgeist hat irgendwie einen Code geschrieben, der Denis hat ihn getestet und ich habe irgendwie das BSD behütet.
Deswegen machen wir eine Ausnahme. Normalerweise gibt es hier nur Club-Marte. Aber heute halt Augustinabreu München. Wieso bist du eigentlich gerade auf dieses Bier gekommen?
Es ist unser Standardbier.
Echt?
Ja, klar.
Ist doch südlich, oder?
In Berlin auch inzwischen.
Bar 23.
Gute Sachen werden beworben.
Das ist, Chaosradio Express ist nur an der Oberseite ein nicht-kommerzielles Projekt. Tief unten ist es schwer vernetzt.
Deswegen sagt doch immer Apple.
Was glaubst du über den ganzen Kram, der hier rumsteht?
Na, wie auch immer. Kommen wir doch mal wieder aufs Thema.
Wir sind ja umgezogen, als es in seiner Küche zu warm wurde.
Ihr habt auch einen Blog. Da habt ihr zu dem ganzen Sachverhalten rund um OpenTracker berichtet. Stories from an OpenTracker. Was gibt es da so zu berichten? Was passiert denn eigentlich so in dieser Szene?
Am Anfang haben wir uns noch die Pakete ein bisschen reingelauscht mit TCB-Dump, also wo man Pakete mit schniffeln kann, weil wir uns gewundert haben, warum denn so eine Menge Connections defekt sind. Das kann man ja schön in seinem OS gucken, welche funktionieren und welche nicht, oder wie hoch der Anteil der funktionieren ist. Das sieht man ja. Und dann haben wir zum Beispiel festgestellt, dass die mit einem Reset-Paket abgeschossen wurden. Dann haben wir ein bisschen geforscht und herausgefunden, dass die Reset-Pakete anscheinend gar nicht von der gegenüberliegenden Seite kommen, sondern wahrscheinlich vom Provider, der davor sitzt, weil der nicht will, dass die betont machen. Das wurde sozusagen injectet. Da haben wir schon versucht, uns ein bisschen was gegen einfallen zu lassen.
Wir reden jetzt von den Verbindungen zwischen dem Client und dem Tracker. Genau. Hält der denn die ganze Zeit diese Verbindung aufrecht?
Aber was reicht er, wenn du...
Das ist ja ein Request, ein HTTP-Request. Der verbindet sich und in dem Moment wird er irgendwie weggehauen.
Der sperrt den Original-Request, wo dieser HTTP-Request drin steht. Also wir haben ja Zündung, Akku und Zündakku usw. beim TCP-Connection. Und dann haben wir das eigentliche Datenpaket mit dem HTTP-Request. Das wurde weggefetert und anstelle dessen wurde ein Reset-Paket geschickt. Und das ist dann bei uns angekommen und hat die Verbindung zerstört. Und wir haben das daran erkannt, weil der Kleine natürlich, wenn er kein Acknowledge für sein Datenpaket bekommen hat, hat er das Datenpaket nochmal gesendet. Und das kam dann mit der gleichen Sequenz nochmal wie das Reset-Paket. Und daran haben wir erkannt, dass es eine Injection sein muss. Ich glaube jetzt hat es die Leute verlassen.
Okay, aber mit anderen Worten, irgendjemand ist dazwischengegangen. Die ISPs haben sozusagen verhindert, dass ein BitTorrent-Kline mit einem Trecker Verbindung aufnimmt.
Die Inbox-Kisten, die ins Layer 4 reingucken, gucken sich das Paket in Inhalt an, erkennen, dass es ein BitTorrent-HTTP-Request ist, blocken den und zerschießen den mit so einem Reset-Paket.
Woran können sie erkennen, dass es ein Trecker-Request ist?
Dass er an den Info-Hash immer da ist. Der Info-Hash muss immer da sein. Den Info-Hash könnte man sogar anders nennen. Das kann jeder machen, wie er will. Aber der Info-Hash muss laut Standard Info-Hash heißen. Und den schießt man einfach weg.
Und HTTPS, der Krypto-Overhead. Und es ist schon jemand mal auf die Idee gekommen, dieses Trecker-Protokoll auch noch zu überarbeiten. Das passiert gerade.
Also, Pirate Bay ist gerade dabei, das Protokoll zu überarbeiten. Unter anderem auch aus dem Grund, weil jedes Mal in den Request schon in den String-Info-Hash reinzuschreiben, sind 9 Bytes. Wenn man das einfach mal für die 3000 Verbindungen pro Sekunde, die da reinkommt, reduziert, kann man schon mal Traffic sparen. Und da stehen irgendwie noch mehr Parameter drin. Die könnte man alle viel, viel, viel mehr verkürzen. Und da gibt es auch gerade Bestrebungen, das zu tun.
Ich meine, ist das nicht relativ einfach zu machen, dass man sagt, hier Leute, wir haben uns jetzt mal auf was geeinigt?
Das ist ein Henner-Eye-Problem so.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn Pirate Bay sagt, wir unterstützen das jetzt mit unserem Tracker, das wäre dein Open-Tracker. Ja, und vor allem, sie können ja ein Fallback machen. Ich meine, jeder Klein kann es auf die neuen...
Das Problem ist, es juckt die Kleinen schlicht nicht.
Warum?
Den Kleinen sind die Tracker sowas von scheißegal. Das sind irgendwie ziemlich gierige Leute, die sind ziemlich maßlos. Die wollen einfach haben, haben, haben. Und die feuern dann ihre Kleines ab.
Wieso? Aber ich meine, wenn der... Ja, aber die Tracker können ja dann irgendwann sagen... Ja, wieso? Aber wenn dir der ASP dazwischen geht und sagt irgendwie, du darfst dich nicht mehr mit deinem Tracker verbinden.
Das scheint nicht genug zu passieren.
Dann gehen sie zu einem anderen Tracker.
Na und wenn der Tracker irgendwie... Diejenigen, die mit dem richtigen Protokoll kommen, irgendwie für sechs Monate lang belohnt und den irgendwie...
Was wäre die Belohnung?
Na, mehr IP-Adressen, wo auch Daten sind.
Dann machen die Packs und dann ist es auch wieder egal.
Also es gibt nicht so richtig Sanktionsmöglichkeiten.
Na gut, aber ich weiß nicht. Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die Kleinen an die Kürze einen Vorteil haben.
Ja, man kann mit denen auch allen reden. Ja, so groß ist ja... Und den Pirate Bay Mininover irgendwie das machen.
Ich meine, es geht ja nur um ein kleines Paket am Anfang.
Man muss sich halt drauf einigen.
Es gibt ja schon... Es gibt doch schon eine Alternative. Also es gibt doch schon die Alternative, einfach ein UDP-Paket loszuschicken. Das geht ja. Das muss man einfach nur eintragen. Die meisten Tracker können das jetzt.
Wo noch viel Random Noise drin ist, damit man irgendwie...
UDP kann das können. Das ist einfach nur ein kleines Paket, da muss nur eins hin.
Mir geht es jetzt darum, dass es nicht mehr so leicht zu erkennen ist.
Das kann man leicht zu erkennen.
Das ist eigentlich noch schlimmer. Also wenn das weggefiltert wird, da kriegen wir es ja nicht mal mit. Aber es wäre auf jeden Fall weniger Last für unseren Trackern.
Jedenfalls, solche Geschichten stehen da in dem Blog.
Die Stories from OpenTracker.
So die Dinge, die uns im täglichen Betrieb von diesem Gerät sozusagen begegnen.
Wir haben ja auch damals versucht, noch eine neue Heimat zu finden für unseren Trackern. Was ein ziemlich lustiges Unterfangen ist.
Ja, da können wir jetzt mal draufhören, glaube ich. Wir haben uns dann mal so einen Routeserver geklickt. Einen namenhaften Routeserver-Anbieter.
Einen Routeserver.
Das ist jetzt mal wirklich sozusagen keine Werbung. Und Hezner, da war das alles schön. Wir haben unseren Rechner bekommen und haben dann eine Freebase installiert. Du hast aus dem DINUX erstmal eine Freebase gemacht. Wir haben dann halt angefangen und dann trudelten die ersten Stats ein und so. Und das war alles schön. Und dann war der Rechner weg. Aus, vorbei, nicht mehr erreichbar. Dann haben wir Hezner gefragt, was ist denn los, wieso geht denn der Rechner nicht mehr? Und dann meinte der Hezner, da wäre eine Denial-of-Service-Attacke am Laufen. Und nun ist es halt einfach so, dass so ein Betriebsfeld auch einfach aussieht, wie die Denial-of-Service-Attacke. Da kommen halt irgendwie 3000 Request auf HTTP reingeballert und irgendwie noch 600 Request pro Sekunde per UDP. Und das sieht schon für einen Admin, der nicht weiß, was das ist, sieht das aus, als würde da eine Denial-of-Service-Attacke laufen.
Der Rechner hat sich mit unserer Software gelangweilt und die sauber, schön abgefeuert und beantwortet.
Das Lustige war noch, dass sie das auch abgeschaltet oder bemerkt haben, dadurch, dass ihre Router davor gestorben sind.
Die konnten nicht so viele Pakete pro Sekunde.
Wir wunderten uns im Trace-Route, dass dann erstmal die IP-Adresse davor ausging, das war ja Router, dann war die davor wieder da, dann ging unser Rechner nicht mehr, dann ging irgendwie der Router wieder nicht. Und daraufhin schrieben sie uns dann halt, dass da die Null-of-Service-Attacke wäre und ihre Infrastruktur mit Leidenschaft genommen würde. Und wir haben gesagt, da ist keine Null-of-Service-Attacke, wir treiben da einen relativ hoch frequentierten Web-Server, was ja nicht gelogen ist. Und darauf meinen sie, ja, wir gucken hier gerade und wir sehen, da läuft Peer-to-Peer. Und Peer-to-Peer ist laut unseren AGBs nicht erlaubt. Dann haben wir geschrieben, aber das ist gar kein Peer-to-Peer, wir sind ja ein Server, wir machen ja kein Peer-to-Peer, das ist klassisch Klein-to-Peer, also Klein-to-Server. Genau, und dann haben sie uns wieder gesperrt und dann haben wir irgendwie rumgemosert und dann wollten sie uns nicht mehr haben und dann haben wir ihn irgendwie erkündigt und dann sind wir wieder zurückgegangen.
Also hier steht gar nichts von Peer-to-Peer in ihren AGBs, die haben gelogen.
Es gab da nicht in den AGBs, sondern es gab da halt noch ein extra Dokument für die Root-Server.
Man darf die Service keinem dritten Anonymen zur Verfügung stellen.
Nein, das war der andere, das war nicht für uns. Die haben schon reingeschrieben, keine Peer-to-Peer-Technologien.
Ach so, naja, BitTorrent-Server-Protokoll, ich meine klassischer Serverkleinstahl.
Bitte benutzen Sie nicht das Internet, so wie es gedacht wird.
Damit war Hetzen dann gestorben.
Aber die dickste Installation von OpenTracker ist ohne Zweifel die Pirate Bay Installation. Kann gut sein, dass die anderen auch bald noch umsteigen auf OpenTracker?
Nein, nicht so einfach, weil die anderen haben ja ihre MySQL-Backern mit dran.
Wie macht denn das der OpenTracker? Hat der überhaupt eine Datenbank?
Nein, keine konsistente Datenbank.
Das ist auch ein Vorteil, dass am Ende niemand vorbeikommen kann und die Rechner mitnehmen.
Keine persistenten Daten.
Das Ding braucht viel RAM. Hallo, das sind 6 bytes pro Kleint, probiere die da.
Also unsere 1,6 Millionen User verbrauchen so maximal 150 Megabyte.
Okay, also hier steht gerade so etwas wie 160 Megabyte.
Und da aas ich aber auch schon noch rum, weil dann ein paar Vektoren sind, die mehr Speicher allozieren, als sie brauchen. Und das könnte man bestimmt noch, aber...
Also Swappen tut da gerade nichts.
Cool, ja, tolles Projekt, gratuliere. Fand ich ja super, dass es so kurzfristig auch noch so geklappt hat. Dann haben wir es jetzt, oder? Gibt es noch irgendwas Wichtiges, was wir noch nicht erwähnt haben? Weil wir schwatzen ja schon wieder seit Ewigkeiten. Tausend Sachen. Wo informiert sich denn so der BitTorrent-Nerd von heute? Was gibt es denn noch für coole Webseiten, wo man mal so klicken will? Er hat vorhin noch so einen Blog genannt, was...
Na, ich klicke relativ regelmäßig auf townfreak.com. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie er wirklich heißt. Der schreibt auch unter anderem ein Pseudonym und der ist relativ gut in Kontakt mit den ganzen Torrent-Side-Betreibern, also mit Supernova und Pirate Bay und Isohand und so. Der kennt die alle und schwatzt mit denen öfter mal und macht mit denen Interviews und hat auch mal irgendwie so eine Liste der 5 größten BitTorrent-Trecker irgendwie rausgebracht, wo auf Platz 3 waren. Und berichtet auch über diese ganzen Klagen von der MPAA und den ganzen Kram, also alles, was um das Thema betorrent.
Ah ja, und hier ist auch noch meine aktuelle Zahl, sehe ich gerade, wie viel Prozent OH, oh Gott, oh Weier.
Jaja, genau, das ist viel. Das ist wirklich viel.
Das ist echt krass. Fuck, naja, also irgendwie in Deutschland sind es 69, das ist peer-to-peer.
69 Prozent peer-to-peer und davon?
Genau, also in Deutschland ist 69 Prozent des gesamten Treffings peer-to-peer. In Osteuropa ist 83 Prozent des ganzen Treffings peer-to-peer. Sagt das was aus, vielleicht? Das ist auf jeden Fall am meisten. Wobei komischerweise North America hier nicht dabei ist. Das ist jetzt hier Deutschland, Osteuropa, Südeuropa.
Das ist doch eine deutsche Firma, die die Statistik gemacht hat.
Middle East und Australia haben sie noch mit da drin. Strange. Middle East gibt es noch nicht so viel. So, und dann gucken wir doch mal jetzt mal rein. Und in Deutschland, Osteuropa ist so gut zwei Drittel des peer-to-peer-Treffings ist BitTorrent. Und der Rest ist E-Donkey. Ja, vor allem in Südeuropa ist es irgendwie sogar mehr als BitTorrent, interessanterweise. In Australien wiederum stehen sie alle total auf BitTorrent. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist das in Südeuropa und im Mittleren Osten durchaus noch im Einsatz und auch in Deutschland 29 Prozent. Und Nutella noch ein bisschen. Und dann gibt es nur in Osteuropa noch ein Projekt, das habe ich noch nie gehört, Direct Connect. Das bestimmt wieder so eine polnische Erfindung, so wie dieses...
Also rein von der Bedeutung her ist ja auch ein Microsoft-Net-Meeting. Wie heißt der Kram? Ist ja eigentlich auch Peer-to-Peer-Technologie.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Na gut. Na dann haben wir jetzt alles wunderbar zusammen. Vielen Dank in die Runde für die doch sehr ausführliche Schilderung. Dieses Mal bin ich besonders gespannt, wie ihr Hörer das jetzt mal verstanden haben, wie das angekommen ist. Also bitte schickt Feedback, Chaosradio, RCC, CDE oder kommentieren im Blog. Das würde mich doch sehr interessieren. Und auch die Gäste, wie gut das angekommen ist.
Wenn es gut angekommen ist, machen wir uns nächstes Mal die CPIP für an.
Ja, was auch, genau. Auch Themenwünsche sind immer gerne gesehen. Es kommt ja eigentlich eine ganze Menge rein. Es gibt eine lange Liste im Wiki. Ich schaue da auch von Zeit zu Zeit mal drüber. Auch wenn die Themenfindung bei Chaosradio Express insbesondere sehr sich immer mehr an den Leuten, die greifbar sind, orientiert. Das heißt, man muss ja auch erstmal einen kompetenten Ansprechpartner für alles finden. Aber manchmal forsche ich auch hinterher. Alle mögen Alex, die neueste Systemstimme auf macOS.
Das ist die erste Google-Ad, die auftaucht, wenn man OpenTracker und einen gibt in Google. Dann steht oben so eine Google-Ad, wo irgendwie OpenTracker lalala und es ist so eine Log-Auswertungssoftware für Web-Server und die haben nichts mit uns zu tun. Und als Slogan haben die We track harder, we track more.
Das ist doch ein schönes Motto. We track harder, we track more. BitTorrent wird gemacht. Und wenn ihr selber einen Trecker aufsetzen wollt, der schnell und klein ist, dann empfehlen wir...
Wie zum Beispiel die Wikipedia.
Wie zum Beispiel die Wikipedia, dann empfehlen wir OpenTracker. Denn OpenTracker ist klein und schnell. Und ja, und was ihr alles da so mitmacht, das wollen wir gar nicht wissen. Und ich sage jetzt erstmal Dankeschön in die Runde. Denis, Cryx und Erdgeist. Und dann sagen wir schön Winke-Winke an alle. Bis bald, wieder bei Chaosradio Express.